Õpetaja: Okei, nii et, ee. Et kui me nüüd vaatame näiteks seda, kus me seda tegime. User is onju,
Õpetaja: et näete. Meie ütleme, et Hei, pane siia. Ee, viimasesse. Ee, siin on meil kokku kolm raud. Me paneme need raud ka korra kokku, onju? Meil on header.
Õpetaja: Meil on see põhiliselt see vormi osa. Ja nüüd on meil siin all image input nupukene, et ütleme, et ei joonista see asi, Aga see asi ütleb, et. Kuule, Kui alt tuleb Nihukene event nagu Selected,
Õpetaja: siis hetkel me ütleme, et image data, le lihtsalt pane Huvitav ta Näete. Niimoodi. Pane uus väärtus külge. Image data
Õpetaja: või? See vend, mis tuleb jätta. Ma korra panen selle niimoodi kinni. Teen korra selle lahti ja näitan, et kujutage ette, et see on Child. See nupp on Child. Tony, vaata. Pärand kutsub välja Child I
Õpetaja: ja ta ootab, et alt tuleb mingisugune sõnum. Noh, siin on see tuvi. Ju Tuvi,
Õpetaja: sõ, sõnum jala küljes ja pakikene.
Õpetaja: Siin on nagu see, et Kui tuleb alt selline event, siis me ütleme lihtsalt. See on nagu otseväärtustamine. Jälle on ju, et me ütleme, et meil on siin image Data muutuja. Mis iganes pakikene tuleb alt, siis anna see sisse.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi seda teeb kas see. Peab niimoodi või? Minu meelest on see ikka dollariga. See peaks töötama. Meile ju nägime ka, et tegelikult see töötas. Kui panna Browser käima. Mitte browser, vaid server käima. Kõigepealt siis paneme Kohe, Browser I
Õpetaja: et me jõudsime seda niimoodi kiirelt. Ee, vaadata ka, et ta ei tee järgi siia sisse küll niiöelda.
Õpetaja: Mm Ee, Okei, on
Õpetaja: taustal siin midagi muud käib. Ma panen need kinni. Mis ma praegu nägin, on see, et ta tegi Ma olen lihtsalt käivitab vite, Ee, palun käivita server Bordil. Kaheksakümmend kaheksakümmend üks.
Õpetaja: Siis Ta ütles. Port. Kaheksakümmend kaheksakümmend. Üks on juba kasutusel. Tema automaatselt Võtab. Järgmise Boardi praegu Mul, ee. Käis klassiraha rakendus seal taustal. Mida ma siin eile õhtul veel arendasin, Et ta. See port ei olnud vaba, nüüd on see, vaba, et mul jäi see silma praegult.
Õpetaja: Noh, teeme lahti. Vaatame, kas ee tuleb lahti. Ee, see Asukoht Juice File. Võtan mingisuguse pildi.
Õpetaja: Jah, kuvatakse alla, et see tõesti tuleb niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis peaks muidugi juhtuma, on hoopis see, et see pilt peaks tulema hoopis ee, siia,
Õpetaja: onju, See pilt on vale ja pildi juures oli tegelikult öeldud ka, et pildiga on niimoodi, et ee kasutaja all input i jaoks
Õpetaja: kuva pilti, Komponendiga Atm Image View. Öeldakse seda, et põhimõtteliselt see osa peaks olema eraldi Ee klots. Ja selle sisu on niimoodi, et ee kui pildi Info on null või tühistring, Siis kuva ta vaikimisi pilti niukest pildikest.
Õpetaja: Ma saan selle pildi kuskilt kätte Ka Mul on mingi eelmises projektis kindlasti olemas. Ma jagan, seda ka. Ma võtan pank. Kolmkümmend, üheksa front. Võtame vana
Õpetaja: projekti korraks lahti Ee, ja proovi lihtsalt selle pildi leida, Ma pakun, et on siin kuskil all. Ee, äkki see.
Õpetaja: Mm, Oota, mis haru see siin on? Üldse mingi suvaline haru?
Õpetaja: Võtame
Õpetaja: nii normaalse Haru
Õpetaja: image saate. Noh, okei, siit otse saab copida. Ma proovin saada seda Slacki.
Õpetaja: Noh, kasutab seda sama pilti lihtsalt siis niiöelda,
Õpetaja: ee, saate Slack is selle downloadida.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ikka, download? Aitate siia peale
Õpetaja: sellest, et, ee. See tõstab vaikimise. Minul läheb ta vähemalt ka osta.
Õpetaja: Siin on Selle faili nimi juba minul Ta pani siis selle ee, sulgudes Üks sellepärast, et mul on ilmselt see juba olemas siin kuskil,
Õpetaja: kui vaadata Lihtsalt Atm.
Õpetaja: Kus see, originaal on, siin, et siis lihtsalt teed selle faili ülesse. Control C, Teeme oma projekti lahti.
Õpetaja: Ee, on siis see Tüüpiline koht, kuhu pannakse asju Näete, siin on ka see. Mingi logo on siin. Ja mida iganes, onju,
Õpetaja: et Ee paneks selle siia ka, asja, et sa jälle
Õpetaja: võibolla nii palju võiks ka teha, et panna veel üks alamkataloog. Ka. Seda saate veel ka Kui vaja. Ee, paneme Images.
Õpetaja: See asjad hakkab natuke lapesse minema, et siin on mingi Ccs I failid ja ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, tegelikult võiks siin ka juba hakata veits paremaks asi minema, et pildid vaatan,
Õpetaja: küsitakse ka Skit I lisada, Loomulikult, et on pildid, mida me soovime, et tulevad meil andmebaasist Näiteks kuidagi veebilehele, et need on lihtne vahetada ja nii edasi. Aga näiteks mingid logod. Asjad Mingisugused asjad, mis on nagu üldkasutatavad need võib täitsa vabalt panna ka siis niiöelda serverisse endasse. Niiöelda,
Õpetaja: et ee, mõlemad mõlemat pidi on Okei, ka ka neid saaks tegelikult laadida andmebaasi nii Kuidas, kuidas see plaanib?
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt läksid. Võtsid. Ee, selle.
Õpetaja: Vabandust, ee, vale asi, et. Ee, lihtsalt. Ee, download I taustast. Lihtsalt Copid.
Õpetaja: Tuled, lähed selle faili peale võeti. Control C, Tuled siia õigesse kausta
Õpetaja: Paned. Control V ja siia. Ta tulebki
Õpetaja: nii, sest et see on osa sellest lahendusest. Niiöelda, mis meil peab tulema.
Õpetaja: Kui minna Location View Sse, siis ee Tavaline imidž Ee, asi. Noh, kas teil on see või Ei, ole. Ma ei mäleta, Ma vist komitesin selle. On ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, et siis võib teha, niimoodi. Et Ee,
Õpetaja: võime selle siis esialgu kattida. Küll Tõstame ta siis õigesse, Ta peaks olema ju. Ee. Minu arusaama järgi ta peaks olema keskmine Row. Vabandust, on esimene. Row,
Õpetaja: kus meil on Heeder on teine ja siis on kolmas. Row, kus on see valipilt? On hetkel tegelikult selle. Me ei jäta selle vormi sisse, et ta peaks olema siis keskmise Rou Kolm Kolm on ju.
Õpetaja: Kui me paneme kõik need Ee Road kinni. Endal siin üks, kaks, kolm, selle keskmise lahti. Meil on siin. Kolumnid,
Õpetaja: on ju? Näete, siin on see place solder.
Õpetaja: Selle võiks siia tõsta.
Õpetaja: Kas ta nüüd. Kas nüüd ma teed selle katiga. Või võtad niimoodi? Näiteks Control Iks tuleb. Paned siia asemele.
Õpetaja: Saate aru,
Õpetaja: et me lihtsalt tõstame ta nagu õigesse kohta. Nüüd võiks natukene seda tuunida ka, et siin tegelikult mingit klasse ega midagi ei olegi
Õpetaja: alt. Noh, võib panna pangaautomaadi pilt, Mis see alt? Oli? Kas Keegi ütleb mulle, Mina ei tea. Jah. Kui mingil põhjusel image it ei suuda ära reederdada, siis ta näitab niukest väikest ikooni, et pilt on katki. Ja tekst on juures. Ja pluss siis nagu need
Õpetaja: Ee Vaegkuuljad. Ee, vaekuuljad. Vaegnägijad. Nendele on siis kuidagi ka abi, aga paneme talle natukene stiili ka
Õpetaja: Ma paneks siia Glass ja image Stamnail.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin võib olla, niimoodi? Et sõltuvalt pildi suurusest on vaja päriselt siis kasutada. Kas mingid Cc sätted või panna mingid piksleid paika? Vaata, et ta liiga suur ei ole. Ee, korra võib siis vaadata, et kas Ta nagu hetkel ujub.
Õpetaja: Vaata, esialgne vaikeseis on see, et pangaautomaadi pilt on katki. Miks sellepärast, et algseis on tühist ring,
Õpetaja: ei suuda tühjast ringi teha. Vaata onju?
Õpetaja: Aga asukoht on nagu enamvähem õige
Õpetaja: minu jaoks. See on ilmselt segane, nagu et miks, nagu,
Õpetaja: miks, nagu need on nagu siin pool. Nagu Kurat, see hakkab mind häirima. Vaikselt juba. Vaatame korra. Kõik asjad on. Rose siin. On nüüd Justify Content Center
Õpetaja: ja Need on tulevad järjest kolumnid.
Õpetaja: Äkki peab sellele kolum ile ka mingi laiuse andma? Samamoodi, Coll.
Õpetaja: Ee, Kaks Või kokku peaks see asi Tulema, siis. Ahah. Vot nüüd juba hakkab nagu normaalsemaks minema.
Õpetaja: Sellel oli kogu ülejäänud laius. Sellepärast ta suruski kõik vasakule,
Õpetaja: et see oli nagu mingi Monster Lai ja siis teised. See oli piiramatu laius.
Õpetaja: Noh, midagi taolist. Vaata, et meil on. See Vali Linn, meil on asukoht. Meil on Pangaautomaadi pilt, kus mitte midagi hetkel ei ole.
Õpetaja: Nüüd võiks selle asja ära lahendada. Selle sama pildi asja
Õpetaja: pildi enda, et hetkel siis on Niimoodi, et kuna see string on tühi,
Õpetaja: siis kahjuks lihtsalt näidatakse katkist pilti.
Õpetaja: Aga meil on taaskis öeldud, et, ee, kui ee, pilte ei ole Siis näidata seda vaikimisi
Õpetaja: pilti, mis? Meil on siin kenasti kuskil
Õpetaja: olemas. Kus Ta on asjad seal. Ime siis siin Näete, onju nii
Õpetaja: Ee, siis kõige lihtsam. Mis mõtted on, kuidas seda teha?
Õpetaja: Näita Ühte pilti või teist pilti. No ma annan siis väikseid vihjeid. Teeme korra. Sellest
Õpetaja: kommenteerib selle alumise. Võibolla korra välja.
Õpetaja: Praegult on ikka. Vaata see. Noh, kus sa oled siin, et pilt katki,
Õpetaja: aga siia Source I asemele. Siis ju.
Õpetaja: Kui me tahame, et tuleks see sisu,
Õpetaja: siis tuleb see siia ära defineerida. Mitte muutujast, vaid nüüd hoopis rajaga.
Õpetaja: Õnneks me Oleme poes. Poes on lihtne asi. Kui sa kasutad ät märki. Siis See fikseeri pankru Source I peale.
Õpetaja: Kui me paneme siia ät kaldkriips,
Õpetaja: et kontrolltühik juba pakub katalooge, Mis on Source I all on nii
Õpetaja: appi, Services. Ja kõik meid huvitab see assets.
Õpetaja: Kaardkriips, Control dek,
Õpetaja: image Is. Kõike seda saab kirjutada ka. Tegelikult, kui te tahaksite vaata, panete A juba ära. Vaata, siis lihtsalt pead nagu Teadma, nagu, mida sul Siin on kirjutada,
Õpetaja: on ju?
Õpetaja: No, mis on Selle nimi? Atm mingi No paned. Kaldkriips. Atm, I bng Vot Nii,
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see pilt siin kenasti olemas.
Õpetaja: Noh, aga meil on nagu, põhimõtteliselt vaja. Nagu üht Või teist Mis mõtet teil siin on?
Õpetaja: Ei, vaata, praegult on see, Vaata, et hetkel hetkel mõtlen niimoodi, et meil hakkab olema läbi selle muutuja. Image data hakkab igal juhul olema. Vaata see, et kus, noh, pilti vaatama. Vaata, et kui inimene valib selle või ma tulen siia lehele, vaata siis selle image data järgi. Me kavatseme seda asja nagu teha,
Õpetaja: Aga meil on point. Vaata seda, et me vaatame elementides. Meil ongi täpselt selline seis, et me tahame näidata ka seda või seda Aga mitte kunagi mõlemat. Siis Mis mõtted on?
Õpetaja: Mul on nagu ohuri töö.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis, kuhu sa selle tingimuse lause paned? Mis tingimus lause?
Õpetaja: Täpselt Eiffe. Oleme niimoodi varem teinud vaata, näitan. Ära näita,
Õpetaja: kui sa paned põhimõtteliselt siia sisse.
Õpetaja: V If.
Õpetaja: Millal me tahame seda näidata? Seda Fix Pilti.
Õpetaja: See peab mingi tingimuslause kirjutama. Mis ma pean kirjutamas?
Õpetaja: Mõjumärk veel ei ole Teemaks nagu. Nüüd on küsimus, on see nagu, et Et Mille pealt me siis vaatame? Seda tingimust, Et kas seda näidata või mitte.
Õpetaja: Mille pealt me vaatame?
Õpetaja: Mhm.
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: aga kas vastab tõele? Vaata, et praegult see on katki. Miks, miks, Miks see alumine pilt on katki? Ma kommenteerin korra välja. Miks, miks praegult?
Õpetaja: Miks praegult? See on katki. Vaata, kui ta nüüd suudab Refresh I uuesti ära teha.
Õpetaja: Miks see pilt? Miks seda pilti ei ole võimalik näidata,
Õpetaja: miks praegu On see pilt katki,
Õpetaja: mitte?
Õpetaja: No okei, Fair enough. No ma võin seda võin siit valida ka pildi. Vaata, et näiteks siis vaata, on ju et. Okei? Et praegusel juhul, Kas vastab tõele, et praegusel juhul me seda katkist pilti ei sooviks näha?
Õpetaja: Kui aga ma valin mingisuguse Pildi Võtame Näiteks selle sama siit.
Õpetaja: Siis me soovime seda näidata. On ju, et hetkel me seda, Ah, mis sa nüüd teed
Õpetaja: Hullult, nagu mõtleb, mida sa teed siin
Õpetaja: nii hetkel. Ta näitab seda pilti, on nii?
Õpetaja: Aga kui siin ei ole midagi, ma teen Refresh I, et Kui siin selle
Õpetaja: see limits data on tühi, siis me seda ei soovi näidata Siis me sooviks hoopis näidata seda ülemist, on nii?
Õpetaja: Noh, Aga Siin ei olegi teie vastus. Vaata, et millega. Me peame siis midagi tegema.
Õpetaja: Image data. Ga, Peamegi tegema. See ongi ju meie andmed ju andmete pealt Soovime otsustada.
Õpetaja: Noh, image data. Ga. Nüüd, Minu meelest ta peaks töötama automaatselt nüüd korrektselt.
Õpetaja: Kui on tühistring või nal, siis rehkendub. Ee, False iks. Kui seal on midagi, vaatame ka ära.
Õpetaja: Ahah, ikkagi ei ole niimoodi.
Õpetaja: No siis on. Millal? Soovime näidata seda Meie Jalgseis on selline. Kui me siia lehele saabume. Tema algseis on image.
Õpetaja: Millal me soovime seda seda pilti näidata?
Õpetaja: Vastupidi, just Nato L on mingi väärtus, siis me ju ei soovi vaikimispilti näidata. Jah,
Õpetaja: mis siis on, kui image data on?
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: kas praegu ilma väärtuseta, aga mis Ilma väärtuseta on sellepärast, et image data ei saa. Ta Null ei ole. Näete, kui me siia lehele saabume. Image data ei saa kunagi null olla, Vaid ta saab olla ainult
Õpetaja: tühistrering.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis me saame öelda, et kui image data on tühistrering,
Õpetaja: siis vist pole nagu midagi muud näidata, kui ainult seda on nii?
Õpetaja: Ja siia, siis ütleme veelse, et teisel juhul
Õpetaja: see on. See on Ifels, onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi, et kui ei ole midagi näidata
Õpetaja: kui see image data on tühi, ehk see, millega me siia lehele saabume, siis näita seda pilti.
Õpetaja: Kui Aga seal on mingi sisuline asi. Siis ütleme, et näita. Oota seda mõtet panna Selle näiteks, Noh laenukse pildi töötab,
Õpetaja: et meil on üks Või teine olukord
Õpetaja: Nüüd ettenägelikult. Ee, see asi peab olema kokkuvõttes Atm. S Aa, mis oli? Vaatame, mis siin on öeldud,
Õpetaja: et kuue pilti Komponendiga Atm. Image, et kogu see osa peab tulema. Lihtsalt Atm. Image.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui praegult selle ekstraktiks ja teeks uueks ee komponendiks, mis probleem Siin on
Õpetaja: lihtsalt. See on see lahendus ju. Näita ära. Näita pilti. Vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Kui ma praegu teeks sellest uue ee, komponendi, siis on Üks väikene mure, mis? Ee, ei tohiks olla.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, mis? Mis mure sellega oleks?
Õpetaja: Ma võin selle tea korra ka. Vaata, ärge Teie tehke lihtsalt siia. Vahepeale
Õpetaja: Kaugel me need ee, teile läksid? Ma vaatan korra.
Õpetaja: Õpetaja veb üksteist Ee, Working progress. Neli.
Õpetaja: Mis mure oleks Kui ma. Kui ma praegu teeksin sellest uue komponendi, mis? Mis? Midagi on Natukene nagu oleks halvasti.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, mis oleks, halvasti?
Õpetaja: Ma Teen Siis selle ära, Siis võibolla see muutub visuaalseks.
Õpetaja: Kuss, kuss, kuss.
Õpetaja: Jah, Teen siia parema klõpsu.
Õpetaja: Ee, faktor. Komponent. Ma lihtsalt panen Aa, Mida iganes selle komponendi nimeks.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma tõstan Ee selle sinna ülesse niimoodi, et Aitäh,
Õpetaja: B If. B. See, mis siin halvasti on,
Õpetaja: tata on pull.
Õpetaja: Data T ei olegi vaja. See on eraldi komponent. Tema saab Propsiga.
Õpetaja: Kõik on õige, Andmed on olemas.
Õpetaja: Seda komponenti on võimalik kasutada.
Õpetaja: Noh, näeme ka. Vaata, et ta tegi kõigesti ära. Noh, image Data S antakse kaasa pärandi image data, Misiganes see ka ei ole, Aga see on üks teine mure.
Õpetaja: Siin on üks väike reegel, mida rikutakse hetkel.
Õpetaja: Aa, seal, kallis, on nagu puudutatud kuidagi poole.
Õpetaja: Mkm, pole see täpselt, aga ütle, mis see viga on? Pole divi sees. Ja mis see tähendab?
Õpetaja: Templeid Blokil tohiks tegelikult olla ainult üks Child aga On üks, kaks, kaks, child. I
Õpetaja: Et iga kord, kui te hakkate ekstraktima, vaata niimoodi tuleb see viga sisse. Vanasti Aa, Kui oli voe Kaks oli. Siis Ta andis kohe viga Nagu reaalselt viga.
Õpetaja: Ee, et ee. Sul leht ei laadinud. Teda hakkas midagi kiunuma. Nüüd ta enam Seda kiunu aga See on jälle nagu mingisugune hea reegel.
Õpetaja: Võime Võime küsida. Muidugi, Äkki äkki. Äkki Tegelikult ei olegi enam niimoodi, et äkki Siis kui on Relaxed Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Siis ma võin küsida. Vaata, küsime Cloud I käest. Oota, ma küsiks pigem niimoodi, et mul edaspidi oleks ka kontroll. K. Vaata Minul meeldib terminali alati avada Niimoodi, kui sa plugina on installitud vajad lihtsalt Control K, et mingi et pärast, Kui ma valin Control K, et siis ta oskab teha neid, et näed, valisid sealt need read. Saate aru, kuidas see toimib, onju?
Õpetaja: Ta Nagu paneb kiirelt selle siia. Ee, ma lihtsalt küsin ühe üldise küsimuse. Vaata, et ee, uue kolm.
Õpetaja: Kui teen ee laps komponente
Õpetaja: siis kas Templeid.
Õpetaja: Ee, bloki sees
Õpetaja: peaks olema vaid üks Child Element Või pole sellist soovitust Või Ma ei tea,
Õpetaja: kuidas seda küsida hoida. Nüüd sa Näed, Selected Lines. Nagu, Noh,
Õpetaja: palun väga. Ma loodan, et selle kohta ei hakka rääkima.
Õpetaja: Ma tahtsin tegelikult ee, küsida selle kohta äge
Õpetaja: ee vältimiseks. Vaata, mis ta ütleb. Ee, voe. Kolm ei Nõua enam ühtegi single. Root Element piirangut. See oli voe Kaks piirang Voe kolm töötab fragmentide kasutamist. See Tähendab, Templand võib siseda mitu juurelementi. See on Täiesti kehtiv Voe kolmes.
Õpetaja: Millal kasutad ühte juurelementi? Kui komponendil on vaja Steele, Mis sõltuvad konkreetsest juurest Ahah,
Õpetaja: siis mul tegelikult. Aa. Tundub, et tegelikult enam ei ole see nii teema.
Õpetaja: Vanasti oli Muidugi, mingi error oli ka oli, siis ka see, Kuidas ee. Kas näitas komponendi nime või mitte? Vaata, ma mäletan, seal oli ka mingeid asju.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis meil on siis, kui ei ole kohustuslik, Siis
Õpetaja: kui pole vaja, siis siis võib olla tegelikult väljavalt. Nagu ta ütles, et kui sa tahad mingit selle konkreetses komponendis. Ta. Ta räägib praegu sellest, vaata. Et Noh, teeme selle
Õpetaja: tegelt. Võime selle nagu ära teha ka enda nagu I Guess, Lähme Siis sinna
Õpetaja: või? Oota, kuule, ma vaatan korra. Hästi, korraks Natukene et. Ee, Ärme veel hakka lahmima. Las ta korraks olla. Jätame
Õpetaja: meelde veel vaatasad, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, aga ma võin City Strop down is seda põhimõtteliselt näidata. Mida ta nagu jäp Ib.
Õpetaja: Ta jääb Ib praegult seda, Et, ee,
Õpetaja: näiteks Ee. City stropta on. Meil on ainult üks Element. Onju on Select. Kui ma tõmban sind, kokku mitu last ta on,
Õpetaja: Ta räägib sellest. Vaata, et ee. Kui sa tahad teha siin niukest asja, nagu
Õpetaja: ma ei tea, Style vist on
Õpetaja: kui sa teed niukse Bloki nagu stiili stiiliploki siia ja teed siin mingi Csc sätted. Siis need rakenduvad ainult sellele komponendile
Õpetaja: ja ta räägib, et et kui sa Soovid siin teha mingisugust stiilisätet, siis sul Võibolla see Tv on kasulik, et on üks tšaid, et sa paned sinna ühte diffi. Mingisugused üldised Mingid stiilisäted. Vaata, mis kohalduvad. Niiöelda ta mõtleb seda põhimõtteliselt,
Õpetaja: et Ee, et siis võib see olla kasulik,
Õpetaja: et enam ei ole siis seda Aega oli alatamatu parves Käinud.
Õpetaja: Mis see juurde annab, Et me enam ei tee? Niimoodi Me võime seda jätkata. Lihtsalt siis peabki mõtlema seda, Et, ee,
Õpetaja: seda peab mõtlema, siis tervikuna. Vaata päeva lõpuks. Ee, kui Ee. Näiteks see sama image input onju?
Õpetaja: Siin on juba mingi Glass Ja siin on mingid stiili. Säted Vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Kui vaadata, kes on tema pärand, siis on meil veel siit mingi div konteiner. Vaata, et et need kõik asjad on selle sees. Ja siin nüüd Css. Iga võib tekkida selline mure. Näiteks, et sul on mingid stiilisätted, mis ilusti Praegult kohanduvad kõikidele nendele asjadele ilma probleemideta.
Õpetaja: Aga näiteks on see sama ja konteiner mängivad kokku. Aga asjad võivad katki minna. Ärge seda praegu kaasa teha. Tehke Ee, asjad võivad stiili suhtes katki minna. Kui kuskile tekib mingisugune niiöelda vahele
Õpetaja: et nüüd on kogu see Staff Tegelikult Ee Ei, ole enam otseselt konteineri. Child on nii,
Õpetaja: vaid siin on vahepeal, et iga kord kui me, paneme template ühe Tv siis lõpptulemusesse, Tv on,
Õpetaja: et, ee, selles mõttes. Seal on nagu argumendi koht, et mingid asjad võivad niimoodi. Sul võib olla natukene raske kontrollida, et, ee, kuidas Stiilid kohanduvad. See üks tiiv või kaks divi, või mis Iganes seal. Vahel.
Õpetaja: Ee, võib rikkuda. Ära Vaata, seal Cs on. Niimoodi et ee. On Ikka pärilus ka, et kui sul on nagu järjest, tuleb seal nagu mingid. Aa, nagu asju. Vaata siis need stiilisäted teatud kujul nagu Kohanduvad,
Õpetaja: Eriti. Seal on mingi flexseaded ja asjad. Vaata, kuidas asjad nagu Aa nagu painduvad. Ja kuidas nad kui parem näiteks ee, ekraan läheb Väiksemaks, kuidas asjad hakkavad nagu üksteisega minema, et seal on nagu neid argumente.
Õpetaja: Ee, miks? Võibolla siis, kui ei ole, vaja, siis võibolla pole vaja, et mina, nagu edaspidi. Ee, võtan ka siis selle suuna et. Noh,
Õpetaja: et kui tegelikult ikkagi ei ole vaja. Ja kui voe kolmest Alates nagu otsustati, et ei ole enam seda piirangut, siis
Õpetaja: siis võibolla See on mõistlik
Õpetaja: aga, vaata see, on niimoodi et, kõik asjad ei Ole nii must ja valged. Vaata, et Kui endale tundub. Mingil põhjusel, et see tiiv on ikkagi hea meie jaoks seal, siis kuidagi on hea ka asju kokku võtta, või mis iganes, Vaata,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, et, ee, et selles mõttes võtan need sammud siit tagasi.
Õpetaja: Ma toon võibolla Näite näiteks, kus on nagu asi. Asi võib väga kiirelt lappe minna.
Õpetaja: No, siin on ikkagi Tegelikult see Html on mõeldud niimoodi, et et siia Table Diagram I sisse. See on lihtsalt väike kastikene siin. Sa võid juba jälle lahmida ja Htmel elementidega nii palju, kui tahad, input Box Id. Ja Jumal teab, mida, on ju.
Õpetaja: Aga näed, see ei ole kunagi niimoodi mõeldud, et näiteks siin vahel on näiteks üks div
Õpetaja: See juba hakkab ee. Lõhkuma. Minu meelest ta juba on siia alla ka Joonis. Selle, mis ta ütleb.
Õpetaja: Sa lõhud ära. Vaata ja kui Meil asju pannakse dünaamiliselt kokku. Vaata siis kuidagi. Niimoodi võivadki tekkida probleemid.
Õpetaja: Oletame, kas kas keegi keelaks mul teha nendest kahest asjast Aa üks Aa, alamkomponent Hei,
Õpetaja: et sellest kahest kahest veerust.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahaksin, ma võiks teha selle alamkomponendi. No aga kui ma paneksin nad niimoodi, jätaksin. Oot, oota aga. Childis. Nad peavad tingimata olema tipi sees.
Õpetaja: Siis nagu võibki juhtuda niimoodi et ma panen nad uude. Kohta Nad ei ole selle Tv I sees. See algkoht on ikka niimoodi. Vaata, et ekstraktimise Ma teen niimoodi
Õpetaja: ma Korra võin seda teha. Ma võin, ju onju Ma teen, et, oo. Tee sellest mingi uus komponent. Ee, refactor Boe komponent New Component. Vahet pole, mis ta nimi on, Ma niikuinii Roll Back in.
Õpetaja: Näed, nüüd on ta siin templeid sees on, on ju? Ja nüüd tuleks siia ja mõtleks. Oot, Oot, oot, oot, oot, mis siin Toimub nagu kaks child i
Õpetaja: umbes. Ma arvan, mingi niukse asja pärast. See piirang võetigi ära,
Õpetaja: et, noh, vanasti nagu sa ei saanudki seda teha.
Õpetaja: Või siis sa pidid lõhkuma seda nõuet. Aga siis oleks katki läks.
Õpetaja: Noh, see juba. See juba praegu siin. Muidugi ütleb. Vaata, et Ta on niivõrd palju targemaks. Saanud. Vahepeal, et ta juba ütleb, et ei. Sa ei tohi teha Seda Siin on ju, aga ma Võin öelda, et vanasti ta ei jäänud. Ta ei nöödagi mütsi. Sellise asja kohta, vaid läkski katki. Lihtsalt mõttes saite aru,
Õpetaja: nii ma teen Nüüd, Ee, Vähemalt City. Ei pea roll. Pack Ima
Õpetaja: City Strop Downocation Stable New Component, et
Õpetaja: ee, sest Location views. Me just tõstsime mingid asjad paika, onju nii?
Õpetaja: Võin kiirelt üle ka vaadata. Tobe topeltklõps. Ah, siin on Mingid Dv Mul pole vaja ja ikkagi
Õpetaja: pigem on kõik Sama nii nagu ennem.
Õpetaja: Okei, no super, Ee. Vaatame siis korra edasi.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt võiks öelda, et see asi siin on suuresti paigas, alt on läinud veel puudu. Nupukene.
Õpetaja: Ee, tagasi. Ja Lisa,
Õpetaja: me võime need nupukesed ka ära lisada. Ja ma pakun, et me teemegi kenasti. Lihtsalt jälle Ühe Uue juurde meil on kokku. Siis üks rau.
Õpetaja: Teine rau.
Õpetaja: Kolmas Row Neljas Row.
Õpetaja: Ee, Nii nagu ka varasemalt. Võibolla kõige mõistlikum on Teha niukseid asju niimoodi, et tõmbad nad teised asjad kokku. Lihtsalt nagu
Õpetaja: Kasutage seda kogu aeg. Vaata, et kui te kui te, ei toimeta mingisuguses kohas või? Pange üle need asjad nagu peitu ära. Nagu peaaegu et mida ei ole vaja. Nagu väga vaadata,
Õpetaja: saab täitsa nagu ära panna, Nagu, et, noh, on ju natukene nagu lihtsalt isegi see, et me võibolla otseselt ei pea midagi veel vaatama ja me keskenduga lihtsalt Virrvarr on silme ees vähem nagu
Õpetaja: ja siia. Siis Teeme uue Tv. I on ju?
Õpetaja: Ta ajab, mis ma siia sisse kirjutan, Glass Yourow
Õpetaja: Võib siia panna ka see kohe, et see Justify Content Center ära.
Õpetaja: Me näeme, et eelmistel on see muster tugevalt. Sees Deev
Õpetaja: ja paneme Siia Siis ka. Meil on siis võimalik. Ee, tema niiöelda
Õpetaja: suurust ja kõike seda võimalik jälgida. Ma panen ka siis mingi. Ma ei tea, Paneme lihtsalt kolm neli, hetkel. See tuleb kaks nuppu siia sisse. Midagi Taolist.
Õpetaja: Nüüd nupud. Ee, Kui tahame siia nuppe alla, panna, Mis mõtted on?
Õpetaja: No te
Õpetaja: tegelikult. Seda võib panna isegi peast ka. Ega mul. Minul on need stiilisäted juba tegelikult meeles. Ma võin ette öelda, No Button. On see element, mida me sealt Css ist tahaks.
Õpetaja: Ja nupu nimeks oli üks oli tagasi.
Õpetaja: Oota, ma veel teen tagasi ja anname Vot praegult on ta Niuke kole.
Õpetaja: No kus see nupukene on?
Õpetaja: Noh, vana nupp on ju nagu või nupp. See ei meeldi, Ütleme talle
Õpetaja: Ee, pattan Ptn ja Ptn. Ee, outline sekundari. Näiteks.
Õpetaja: See vist oli. Ma ei mäleta, mis värv peas ta on? Hall
Õpetaja: taskes vist oligi Juhuslikult hall. Ju Noh, see on valge, okei? Outline hall ja teine võiks olla roheline, et teeme dublikaadi lihtsalt sellest reast Control T
Õpetaja: ja Teine on ee. Nupu nimi oli. Mis tal kirjas oli, Lisa
Õpetaja: Ja selle See ei ole enam sinine. Roheline on success.
Õpetaja: Noh, ongi olemas
Õpetaja: Midagi hakkab silma. Hoiad üksteise vastu.
Õpetaja: Mis me siin saaksime teha?
Õpetaja: Tuleme, ütleme kogu aeg. Lükkame endast paremal või all olevaid asju nagu endast eemale, et siin ei ole Mitte Margin Bottom. Seekord vaid Margin end. Ehk siis paremale. Lükka näiteks mingi kaks, Näiteks võibolla lahti,
Õpetaja: Võibolla natuke Rohkem siis kolme.
Õpetaja: Noh, midagi taolist Vaata Mõtlesid ära jälle,
Õpetaja: et see on selle jaoks, et nad ei oleks üksteisega niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, liiga ee, üksteise küljes
Õpetaja: stiiliga saaks siin igasuguseid asju veel mängida, et lükata nad paremale poole ja mida iganes. Vaata, meil nagu see väga ei huvita, Hetkel.
Õpetaja: Ee.
Õpetaja: Noh, disaini mõttes ei tundu nagu mingi maailma kõige ägedam vorm, aga.
Õpetaja: Aga see ei olegi tähtis.
Õpetaja: Okei, mis edasi
Õpetaja: nüüd, Ee, Mina mõtlen, et ee, miinimum, mis võiks teha, on see, et nüüd, kõik need elemendid. Ee, võiks siduda
Õpetaja: mingisuguse muutujaga.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et ee, etteruttavalt Võin öelda seda, et sellest, samast vaatest me tahame teha ka editvaate,
Õpetaja: et kui me tuleme siia, tead, me ei saa seda suurendada. Seda Urli baari. Siin on ju, et kui me tuleme siia vaatele täpselt niimoodi kaldkriips,
Õpetaja: siis meie jaoks on see lisaasukoht
Õpetaja: tulevikus Kui me tuleme Siia see on. Vaata, Fronti. Url, me tuleme siia siia niimoodi, et on
Õpetaja: Id võrdub näiteks kaksteist.
Õpetaja: Siis Meie jaoks. On see juba Edi olukord,
Õpetaja: Sest me tahame kasutada seda sama vaadet lihtsalt uuesti.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on alati valikute küsimus. Ee, kui me tahame teha niimoodi, et nagu Kõiki andmeid on võimalik Nagu muuta. Nagu et ütleme, et mingi mingi info, hulk nagu õpilase andmed,
Õpetaja: siis me oleme juba välja töötanud selle vormi, kuidas lisada andmeid ja lisamisel. Ee, kui on see ühe sammuga lisamine et ei ole kuidagi mitme sammu peale jaotatud, siis suure tõenäosusega Kõik võimalikud andmed, mis selle nagu õpilase kohta saaks panna, on juba sellel lisamise vormil olemas.
Õpetaja: Ja kui eesmärk on see, et me saame neid kõiki muuta, siis see sama vorm ju sobib ju suurepäraselt.
Õpetaja: Ja kui sul on mingi väike variatsioon, näiteks et muutmisel mingit ühte asja ei saa, siis me saame mingi veef iga kontrollida seda. Vaata, et muutmisel ühte välja ära näita. On nii.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, ee, kui me mõtleme Nagu sellele ka, et päeva lõpuks me peame saatma välja sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Korra Panen selle balsamiku ette. Sellepärast, et seal oli see kõik nii hästi ju näha.
Õpetaja: Ee, visuaalsemalt, kui Ee, taask seda praegult siin hakkaks meil selgitama. Kuigi see on seal kõik ilusti kirjas.
Õpetaja: Kui tahad hakata saatma, Kui on täidetud variant. Kõik andmed on olemas,
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, et lõpuks peaks minema Niukene Jason Teele City Id, üks Location name number of Htm. Simage data transaction types. Mis on selline massiiv,
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Siis
Õpetaja: oleks vist mõistlik et, kõik asjad mida, kasutaja valib mäletate, see Ee, kõik, mis meil ee on. Niiöelda selles sõnumis, mis me lõpuks peaks ära saatma,
Õpetaja: siis meil olekski mõistlik teha täpselt sellise mudeliga niiöelda muutuja ja väljad.
Õpetaja: Ja siis tehagi, niimoodi et kõik, mis on siin valitud, Flob sinna alla
Õpetaja: ja kõik, mis alt niiöelda Child Ides muudetakse, Kui keegi kirjutab siia mingi sisu, tuleb meil automaatselt siia
Õpetaja: Se selle nagu muutuja Niiöelda objekti väärtusel.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis lõpus. Kui seda lisa nuppu Vajutad
Õpetaja: siis selleks hetkeks juba. Tegelikult taustal andmed ongi õiged ja korrektsed siin olemas.
Õpetaja: See võib natuke praegu segane teie jaoks olla. Aga see Lõpptulemus oleks niikuinii selline, et ma räägin teile nagu. Mis? Ma nagu mõtlen,
Õpetaja: et me võiksime praegu teha siin vabalt neid data blokki muutuvaid Image data ja.
Õpetaja: Ja no mis siin on meil? Vaata, võtame selle kasti lahti. Ee, esimese Mitte esimese. Vaid teise,
Õpetaja: et meil on ju Siin Sees asukoht. Infot on nii?
Õpetaja: Olete nõus?
Õpetaja: Me saaksime põhimõtteliselt seda teha, niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Et meil oleks eraldi muutuja Location Name.
Õpetaja: No ma teen selle läbi Location name.
Õpetaja: Me saaksime siduda selle selle kastiga.
Õpetaja: Aga siin on nüüd üks
Õpetaja: mure. Vaata, et isegi kui ma paneks selle location, Name I eraldi. Järgmine kast on automaatide arv
Õpetaja: input number of. Ma saaksin teha eraldi muutuja
Õpetaja: Number of See oli kaasatäimise koht Atm S
Õpetaja: Ja panna siia näiteks vaikevahetuse nulli. Ma saaksin teha need muutujad, mis Ma seon selle kastiga.
Õpetaja: Aga see hetk, kui ma vajutan,
Õpetaja: et Lisa uus automaat. Noh, siis kui minna ja vaadata svage reditori.
Õpetaja: Me näeme, et mida? Me peame teele saatma.
Õpetaja: See jutu on kaasategemise, või
Õpetaja: kui Me otsime svage reditori ülesse.
Õpetaja: Kus on see teenus, millega sa puud pangaautomaati lisada.
Õpetaja: Tegu sõna juba ütleb. Siin peab olema onju
Õpetaja: post Api Atm Location, uue pangaautomaadi asukoha lisamine.
Õpetaja: Image Data Transaction Type Name pole kohustuslikud väljad. Aga on see, et meie teenus ootab siukest. Asja
Õpetaja: näete siin praegult. Ta peegeldab niimoodi, Nagu meil päris süsteem näitab. Näete, vaata, see siin ei ole nagu päris näidet. Vaata, taga. Mul ei ole eksamplit seal. Mul on lihtsalt skeema,
Õpetaja: kohustuslikud väljad ja nii edasi. Ee, et
Õpetaja: see selline sõnum peab lõpuks minema teele,
Õpetaja: nii kui nüüd võtame Copy Base. Sellest ma ei tea, siin vist ei näitab. Ei näita seda kunagi. Siis, kui päris sõnum, siis vist näitab,
Õpetaja: et võtame selle Hästi, Ettevaatlikult, Copiga.
Õpetaja: Mis asi see on? Post Atm Location, onju? Jätame selle meelde. Post Atm Location. Kui me nüüd tahame niukest mudelit, teha. Siis meil läheb vaja. Esiteks,
Õpetaja: mis meil läheb? Vaja. Meil on vaja muutuja nimesi mingisugust.
Õpetaja: Mis võiks olla selle muuta nimi,
Õpetaja: kui praegu isegi Teame, et see teenus on näiteks Post Atm Location.
Õpetaja: See on Location View.
Õpetaja: Mis võiks olla muutaja nimi.
Õpetaja: Need on andmed, mille kohta, puhast Kolmeteist
Õpetaja: võiks ka olla. Aga. Aga pärast, siis, kui seda sama keha tahaks ka näiteks update imiseks kasutada, siis see muuta nimi New Location Nagu Ei, oleks enam
Õpetaja: väga hea. Vaata et siis, on mingi updated location Onju? Aga sisu saab olema neil täpi pealt sama.
Õpetaja: Miks te Nagu nii keeruliseks teete seda.
Õpetaja: Ad location. Muutuja Nimesid ei tohi tegusana olla.
Õpetaja: Vot see oli hea pakkumine. Öelge kõva häälega uuesti, kes ütles
Õpetaja: Location Post Location. Me tegime ennem ju tabeli ka. Vaata, et kui tõmbame alla, Vaata, vaatame seda. Location Stable. Mida tema sisse võtab,
Õpetaja: kui Kuvame
Õpetaja: Location Id oli ka locations, et. Noh, sel sellel oleks. Sellel oleks. Ee. Siin oleks võibolla ainult ruumi. Mingi,
Õpetaja: Ee, ainu ainukene variatsioon, Mida võibolla võiks mõelda? See oleks siis, kui meil süsteemis on mingisuguseid mitmeid erinevaid location eid. Nagu mitte see, et mitmeid erinevaid location eid Mitu erinevat, vaid, et meil on näiteks meie kontori asukoht.
Õpetaja: Meie kontorid
Õpetaja: ja meie pangaauto. Seal oleks nagu süsteemis tekiks üsna kiirelt, nagu et Üks peab olema igal juhul mingisuguse. Vaata, onju midagi? Ta Mingisugune location. Ta peab olema kaks location it siis juba parem oleks et, noh, Mõlema ees oleks näiteks Atm Location ja.
Õpetaja: Ja ma ei tea Office Location või kuidas Kontol on üldse nagu kontol, kus saab tulla nagu,
Õpetaja: Kuidas inglise keeles, nagu see on?
Õpetaja: Kuidagi Kõlab nagu inimesed istuvad ja klõbistavad seal. Aga tegelt on nagu see, et et noh, tule, nagu Saad siin kohapeal teha.
Õpetaja: Noh, jah, et, ee. Siis oleks seal Point I. Aga praegult on meil location. Teie võtate muidugi teadmiseks, et, ee, Noh, see on nagu kaalutluskoht alati. Aga alati, mida lihtsam seda parem, ju
Õpetaja: me hakkame seda muuta igal pool nägema ja me praegu näeme, et me tegelt oleme võtnud niikuinii niukse suuna, et me kutsume neid Location Iteks. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: see on Location View. No mida sa siin post Ida saad. Location Eid, siis Location oleks suht hea.
Õpetaja: Paneme siia, Paneme Control V.
Õpetaja: No kurivaim. See minul ta ka ei teinud. Ee, ära, neid.
Õpetaja: Ee, Võtan lihtsalt kogu selle teksti osasid suvaliselt täitsa ja on Cold Property nähes
Õpetaja: need String Id need. Ma lihtsalt asendaksin ee, kustutan Ja
Õpetaja: teen niuksed. Üksikkülakomad. Ja nüüd juba copy Based lihtsalt üle.
Õpetaja: Kui ei viitsiks niimoodi. Teha, siis on üks variant veel,
Õpetaja: ma võtan sammudega tagasi, et ei tee. Lihtsalt tehke käsitsi seda korda. Number of Htm. No see võib kaheks panna, et kandja viitab, et ongi mingi min väärtus,
Õpetaja: et, ee. Üks variant on veel, aga sellega peab olema natukene ettevaatlik.
Õpetaja: Control F on see, et otsib,
Õpetaja: et kolm korda leiab siit Ee, sellelt lehelt. Control F. Aga teine variant on Hoopis Control R.
Õpetaja: Mis asi on kontroller final? Replace
Õpetaja: Ma võiks siia panna, et asenda Igal pool stringid, aga nüüd tuleb väga ettevaatlik olla. Vaata, et kui kuskil mujal. On veel. No mul on siin kaks üksiküla koma
Õpetaja: nagu Üks variant on veel. Te selekteerite selle osa
Õpetaja: ja vajutate kontroll R. Siis ta otsib ainult selle selektsiooni seest, et otsin mina String,
Õpetaja: aga Nüüd Ta teeb seda ainult selle selektsiooni seest, et ta kuskilt mujalt ei otsi, onju?
Õpetaja: Kui on niimoodi, palju, neid, siis juba ma teeks niimoodi käsitsi
Õpetaja: teha. Korda ei ole, ka tegelikult suurem asi kunst.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, kui lõpuks, kui me saadame andmeid. Neil on vaja tegelikult seda objekti et panna sõnumile, kaasa,
Õpetaja: siis ei ole väga mõnus et me lõpuks peame. Kui meil oleks eraldi muutujad Location name ile, siis selle nupu vajutusel Me peaksime hakkama lihtsalt andmeid ümber tõstma, et Location punkt number of võrdub
Õpetaja: this number of Htms. Sellel ei ole tegelikult point I Hoopis palju parem asi on see, et aga
Õpetaja: kasutamegi seda objekti
Õpetaja: andmete hoidmiseks. Ja seda me hoiame mõlemat pidi Nagu seda seda objekti. Me Hakkame mõlemat pidi nagu tegema kõik, mis on siin. See sisu see
Õpetaja: Ja vastupidi. Kui sealt tuleb mingi muudatus, siis peab selle objekti niiöelda need väärtused hakkama siin muutuma, et see ongi jälle see. Me hoiame ühte andmeobjekti ja me hoiame teda süngis aga me peame programmeerima selle Süngi ise
Õpetaja: nii.
Õpetaja: Kas ta. See mõte nagu sai selgeks, et miks just teha niimoodi? Siis päeva lõpus, kui me vajutame sen nuppu, me Peame panema Jasoni kaasa sõnumiga,
Õpetaja: kus on andmed, mida me soovime. Lisada süsteemi See ongi see Jason. Seesama Javascripti objekt teisendatakse linnulennult Jasoniks ümber,
Õpetaja: Ja kui ta jõuab otsapidi jaavasse, siis seal on täpselt sama struktuuriga klass
Õpetaja: klassi nimi. Noh, klassi nimi on Savi, mis ta klassi nimi on, aga seal on väljad. Private Integre City Id. Või Noh, long tegemist parem. Ee, Private string ee location name private number of private
Õpetaja: Ee, string Aa. Saate aru. Seal jaavas saab olema täp. I pead sama klass
Õpetaja: ja Ja meie eest on juba ära tehtud see, vaata, et Ee, raamistikud toimetavad ise mõlemal pool meie eest.
Õpetaja: Et ee, ühtepidi on, niimoodi, et kui siin pool on niimoodi, et sissetulevad andmed andmed tulevad Jasonina programmis. Me Jasoniga ei toimeta. Jason on string.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt, Mis trend on tekst lihtsalt
Õpetaja: javascriptis. Me toimetame ja avascripti objektidega
Õpetaja: samamoodi. Me ei toimeta tekstiga, vaid me toimetame java objektidega. Aga kuna see Jason on standard, siis mõlemas tehnoloogias, on see juba meie eest kenasti ära Timmitud,
Õpetaja: et automaatselt meie eest. Lihtsalt, ee. Kui tulevad sõnumid sisse ja lähevad välja, siis tehakse teisendusi.
Õpetaja: Pane selle teele
Õpetaja: Ja läheb Fronti front võtab selle Jason I vastu teeb ja avascripti objektiks. Erinevad objektid ja avascriptis java objektid. Programm, javas java objektid. Noh, see on meie mängumaa Keskel on siis Jason? Mis ülihästi peegeldab seda struktuuri ka
Õpetaja: palju paremini. Miks on veel? Miks on veel rõve? Ma korra panen, Ma ütlen, Nagu ma ütlen. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Võtan näiteks selle sama. Jason i siit.
Õpetaja: Ee. Ma võtan selle Jasoniga
Õpetaja: ära. Ee, Chatile see on vaatamise koht. Saaksite aru, et ega neid sõnumi formaate on erinevaid Ee chatcha chat.
Õpetaja: Noh, mine nüüd.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen talle.
Õpetaja: Tee mingi näidis.
Õpetaja: Ladis, Jason
Õpetaja: Skeema,
Õpetaja: Ma Annan ta lihtsalt ette Selle põhimõtteliselt tee. Mingi Jason.
Õpetaja: Em,
Õpetaja: ma ei tahtnud skeemat. Tee lihtsalt näidisandmetega.
Õpetaja: Andmetega või kui palju taipas ja Ka vast saab aru.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis Disflow käik? Jah,
Õpetaja: noh, mingisugune objekt. Tallinn City Center Atm Base Kuuskümmend. Nad ise juba teab. Seda. Ma Olen ta midagi ette öelnudki. On ju
Õpetaja: nii? Cashfui Draw.
Õpetaja: Oh, muidugi. Noh. Saad näha automaadist. Saad näha konto Jääki Üli Üliõta et nagu Kõigil automaatidel võiks justkui olla. On ju? Vahet pole, aga mõte on nagu olemas, onju? See on ee, nüüd selline. Niiöelda tekst, mis, mida Saab inimene aru. Ja mida saab arvuti aru, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ma nüüd ütlen. Tee sama näidis, Isml. Iga.
Õpetaja: Noh, vanasti olid enamus sõnumid olid Xml. Iga
Õpetaja: see on täppi pealt. Sama asi. Näete, aga ta on teistmoodi. Location Algab Location lõpeb. Ta on nagu Html,
Õpetaja: Tuleb Väli City It väärtusega sada. Üks location name transaction types. See on massiivobjektidest. Saate aru sama sisu Aga mis te arvate, kumb on loetavam
Õpetaja: kas see Või meeldiks seda lugeda. Jah,
Õpetaja: ee, mis te arvate? Kumb on tänapäeva standard?
Õpetaja: No muidugi, see on. Isegi see on Spring Raamistik on niimoodi. Kui sa saadad sõnumit, sa peaks tegelt ütlema tegelikult, talle et. Kuule, siin on jaava jaava objekt. Nüüd, kui saadad serverist välja, milleks see Teisendaja
Õpetaja: saaks öelda Mingi accept. Jason, mis iganes. Mingi. See on vaikimisi juba vaikimise säte. Sa pead isegi seda ütlema. Vaata, et teed Jason Iks.
Õpetaja: Sest et Jason on see.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma arvan, et see on nagu Self ex Planetari.
Õpetaja: See on pigem pool meetrit.
Õpetaja: Ee, see see Ei ole pi Pigem pakun, et tegemist on nagu selles mõttes, et vanasti nii oli. Ee, suured maksesüsteemid.
Õpetaja: Ehk see on veel
Õpetaja: et Aa Pea Enamus süsteemid, millega mina kokku puutusin, maksesüsteemid. Aa, niiöelda siis suured maksesüsteemid, mis on pankade vahelised,
Õpetaja: Aga Kui mina, lhv St. Teen kanda Teen Swed. Ega see ei lähe otse Swed I maksesüsteemi, millest noh, makstakse. Raha, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, ka. Vaata, et keegi ju vahendab, keegi Keegi on nagu teinud selle üle maailma liidestuse ära, et teeme niukse online süsteemi, Saame makseid üksteise vahel saata ja
Õpetaja: keegi, kes kontrollib, et Tuleb sisse Sõnum, et see on nagu mingi. Okei, seal on kõik nii nagu peab. Kuhu see peab minema? No keegi teine korjab selle Maksu. Üles, et tegelikult see otsesuhtlust ei käi. On ju,
Õpetaja: et inimestel võib mulje jääda. Vaata, et vanasti olidki. Saatsid kuskile ee. Välissüsteemi või Saatsid välisriiki kuskile Inglismaale Mingisse panka. Saatsid mingi makse. Kunagi Sa välguna ei läinud, onju? Euroopas isegi mitte, ee. Pidid seal ootama mingi paar päeva. Vaata, enne kui papp tuleb ee üle
Õpetaja: ja siis võikski mõelda nagu, et. Aa, okei. Noh, sinna kuidagi panka peab see jõudma nagu Mingi, et läheb? Ma ei tea postiga.
Õpetaja: Miks ta nii kaua läks? Ma ei teagi. Ee, et. Ee. Kuidas see süsteem toimib, tegelikult on Clearing Times. See on niimoodi, et ee,
Õpetaja: maksesüsteem siis. Ee, tea. Iga teatud hetkel Niiöelda ütleme need vanemad süsteemid, kus ei ole nii kiired maksed, aga nad on odavamad.
Õpetaja: Ee, et, ee, et see vanasti oli niimoodi, et on mingid konkreetsed ajad, mis hetkel niiöelda siis see maksesüsteem Kontrollib kõike makseid, mis on sisse tulnud.
Õpetaja: Ja põhimõtteliselt teeb See tegi seal mingid omad, Mingid hookus, pookused, ja omad asjad. Ja siis kõikide Teiste pangasüsteemid läksid sinna süsteemi kontrollima, et kas mul on midagi?
Õpetaja: Noh, see kuidagi niimoodi töötas vähemalt, Noh, võibolla oli see nii
Õpetaja: ja valdavalt olid iksa. Ma olen oma elus näinud küll.
Õpetaja: Jumal Tänatud. Ee, Rohkem,
Õpetaja: et kõik uued süsteemid, mis tehakse. Ma arvan, et seal nagu keegi See meeldi väga naljalt ei valiks. Või siis peaks olema mingi põhjendus selleks, nagu. Et miks? Just see
Õpetaja: nagu Nagu alati, Igal asjal on Mingid omad head ja vead, et see ei ole kunagi niimoodi, Et vaata, et nagu üks on nagu, ee, nagu absoluutselt õige otsus igal pool, et nagu, noh, milleks neid vanu asju on Vaja On ju, et tihtipeale on mingid tugevused ja. Ja plussid nagu erinevatel,
Õpetaja: ee, asjadel, Okei, ee, nii aga liigume edasi. Ehk siis mõte on see, et meie kavatseme kasutada seda objekti
Õpetaja: seda objekti. Ee, süngis. Ee, nende
Õpetaja: nende Input ide ja asjadega ja vastupidi. Süngis käibki Mõlemat pidi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ee Peakski tegema. Seda, et ennem kui me hakkame nüüd lammutama neid ee, Kloitse siit lehelt. Eraldi komponentideks. Teeks niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Et Ee, seome siis praegult kõik need komponendid sellega ära.
Õpetaja: Aga mida me nüüd ei tee, on See, et me ei kasuta veemudelit,
Õpetaja: neid ei pea ei võta tegema või sularaha sisse sularaha välja.
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, et see informatsioon tuleb sisse. Nagu siin taskis. On öeldud ka, et või tegelt. Parem on isegi korra näidata veel seda, et kust nad sisse tuleb? Tühi,
Õpetaja: tühi Get Cities Need andmed tulevad kuskilt. Ehitame dünaamiliselt
Õpetaja: sõnum Back end ile Get transactions.
Õpetaja: Selle Pealt point on see, et kui me praegu hardcode Ime need väärtused sisse. Sularaha sisse. Sularaha välja maksed.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis ongi see, et üks hetk tuleb mingi uus huvitav aparaat, millega saab midagi huvitavat teha. Noh, näiteks Bitcoin või? Mina ei tea, mida iganes. You name it.
Õpetaja: Ja siis oleks niimoodi, et kui muidu läks lihtsalt keegi Ja paneks ühe tüübi andmefaasis lihtsalt ühe scriptiga või lihtsalt kuskil nuppe klõbistades sisse,
Õpetaja: Siis oleks vaja hoopis teenida tellida arendus. Teil on Html is sularaha sisse. Sularaha väljamaksed. Olge nii, paid. Pange sinna Bitcoin juurde. Noh, arendus, analüütik oleneb struktuurist ja hierarhiast. Kuidas ettevõttes on asjad korraldatud Code Review testimine deployment.
Õpetaja: Et lihtsalt andmeid juurde panna, Et, ee, see tuleb ikka ju mujalt.
Õpetaja: Seal on pandud üks või teised need,
Õpetaja: ee, null, et siis on. Kas selle miinimumväärtuse pärast?
Õpetaja: See on lihtsalt vihjeks. Põhimõtteliselt null või üks. Tegelikult ei muuda mitte midagi,
Õpetaja: et sisu Ärme Unusta ära päeva lõpuks, et päriselt on objekt. Kui ma panen ikkagi siia ja panen rain sisse, siis nii on Vaata seal. See sisu. Vaata, Location Is on ka kõik need väärtused, et sa pead midagi panema. Me Eelkõige tahame siin re representida, kuna see sisu tihtipeale tuleb Internetist või see tehakse kokku. On ju.
Õpetaja: Ee, et ee. Siis Praegu me peame isegi panema miks? Sest et kui me tuleme siia lehele Siis see flow alla,
Õpetaja: et meil peab olema, et City Id on null.
Õpetaja: See tegelikult läheb sinna muutuvasse Selected City Id veel by the Way, Et, see peab hakkama sinna nagu minema et, ee
Õpetaja: Location Name tabel alguses. On tühi
Õpetaja: ja number of alguses on üks sest, et See on miinimum. Jah, praegu ei oleks ka nagu. Aga isegi kui see oleks mingisugune asi, mis me ise paneme kokku ja algselt tal Mingit sisu pole. Me võime panna siia põhimõtteliselt mingid algväärtused justkui vihjeks. Vaata, mis seal nagu tulevad, on ju või et see, on miinimum, Nagu praegult on see nagu täiesti lausa vajalik.
Õpetaja: On nagu lausa vajalik Nii toimetame.
Õpetaja: Hakkame ülevalt pihta.
Õpetaja: Aga mis ma nagu ütlesin, et ee, Neid input E. Näiteks see kass. See koht siin Asukoht
Õpetaja: me Ei, kui me ennem tegime, Mäletad, Login, Il. Tegime username, tegime veemodel
Õpetaja: veemodel Ja siis ütleks näiteks praegu, et. Noh, kus? Mis kastiga? Ma tahaksin muidu seda siduda, kui ma isegi praegu kirjutaks sellega, on nii,
Õpetaja: et oleks seotud, et mis iganes on selle sees, läheb sinna kasti. No paneme siia alguses mingi sisu. Aa, on ju
Õpetaja: siis, kuidas ma praegu Kuidas ma saaks öelda, et siia tuleb midagi, et ma seo? Seon selle objekti väljaga, mis ma kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Jah, noh, vaatame korra praegult. Kui Ma tulen siia, siis see A on siin sees.
Õpetaja: Ja Pbb. Siis kui nad on praegu, siis ta automaatselt läheb selle muutuja sisse. Kuidas seda vaadata? Kas kuu vaega on ju? Vaatame, teeme lahti selle natuke suurelt. On see asi. Location View Ee Location on reactive. On tal Pbb sees,
Õpetaja: Noh, kui. Ma muudan selle ära. Ccc muutub
Õpetaja: nii See on kõik väga tore, aga arvestame nüüd, seda, et see koorilõik siin Hakkab olema lõpuks Child Element
Õpetaja: Child Elementi, voolavad andmed ülevalt sisse ja siis tuleb see asi.
Õpetaja: No ma panen ta mul siin teisel lehel.
Õpetaja: Jah, siin on mingi arved Hoopis Aa, vot üks hetk.
Õpetaja: Mäletad seda asja,
Õpetaja: kui meie props ei tohi olla kunagi interaktiivselt seotud ühegi elemendiga, Mis muudaks tema väärtust? Ehk siis veemodel, et kui meie plaan on selline, et, ee, see sõna otseses mõttes, sellest saab ju Child komponent,
Õpetaja: Noh, koos sellega koos. Sellest saab ühel hetkel komponen. See on kirjas Location Name Inpot.
Õpetaja: Siis me ei saa seda interaktiivset elementi kasutada, kuna See väärtus tuleb ülevalt alla.
Õpetaja: See hakkab Propsist tulema.
Õpetaja: Siis meie Praegult. Teeme niimoodi, et me ütleme, et Kuule, selle veemudeli asemel hoopis kasutame Atribuuti value
Õpetaja: ja kool on ka.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis praegult on niimoodi, et me. See, mis on siin, see on nüüd. Ühes ühesuunaline sidumine hetkel,
Õpetaja: et kui minul on endiselt. See. Aa on ju? On siin olemas. Aa,
Õpetaja: kus ta tuleb? No ta tuleb sellest väike väärtusest, mis ma praegu siia niimoodi sisse keevitasin.
Õpetaja: Value on input. Il. Aga kui ma seda muudan, Teeme nüüd selle voe komponendi lahti. Uuesti, Cashion
Õpetaja: Praegult on Location I sees. Aa, kui ma siit näiteks muudan, panen Pbb see sinna alla. On ju,
Õpetaja: et muutuja Aa kasti läheb väärtusena, aga kui Mina panen siin Ccc
Õpetaja: Tikin kuskil korra mujale. Ka. Äkki renderdasin või midagi taolist ei muutu.
Õpetaja: See on ühesuunaline muutuja kasutamine, aga selline asi on nüüd okei? Sellepärast, et kui me ekstraktime selle osa,
Õpetaja: ta kasutab seda Location objekti ja kõik see muusika.
Õpetaja: Aga mis on nagu hea Selle puhul on siis see, et ta ei ole seotud veemudeliga, et me ei hakka nagu seda reeglit vägistama.
Õpetaja: Me Ei, saa veemodale panna, et siin. Kui teeks. Kui kõik teeks siin, siis veemodel oleks perfekt.
Õpetaja: Ise hoiab süngis. Vaata, on ju, et mida on seal selles Location Objektis on ka seal, nendes kastides ja vastupidi muudad. Midagi. Oleks väga Timm. Aga kahjuks niimoodi ei saa.
Õpetaja: Ja see lähenemine, mida me praegu teeme, on tegelikult ka
Õpetaja: see on standard Aa, See on nagu uuem kirjaviis seal taustal. Ta Tegelikult päris palju teeb. Ee, natukene lihtsamate sõnadega, Seal saab kasutada nagu veemudelit igate pidi. Seal on niimoodi, et seal on see ära mees. Nagu programmeeritud paari sõnaga, et välju alla
Õpetaja: Event Toob info üles ülesse ja ta ise hoiab süngis. Oleks võimalik siin ka ühtteist teha. Aga me nagu ei taha, teha, Me tahame teha Täpselt niimoodi, Sest et see on nagu see, kuidas see tehnoloogia tegelikult töötab.
Õpetaja: Props alla ja mitte üles Props alla ja mitte üles asju Tuleb süngis hoida, programmeerides.
Õpetaja: Ühesõnaga, miks mulle ei meeldi tegelikult see? Ee Praegusel hetkel ei tahaks seda Õpetada Ongi see, et seal hakkab seal Karukõhus. Ee, nagu Lhv S. Oli alati kogu aeg see väljend. Vaata, et sprint teeb sinu eest midagi seal kuskil ära. Karu kõhus. Kuskil Midagi toimub. Alati oli see väljend,
Õpetaja: et sa ei näe Koode ei näe karukõhus.
Õpetaja: Ee, meil oli niuke väljend. Okei teeme siis teised asjad Samamoodi, et me saame väljusi, saame anda. No, siin on number Ee. Automaatide arv. Input box. Tuleme samamoodi. Kaldkriips, Välju, mitte kaldkriips. Kool on Value Location objekt. Ja siia tuleb, Siis
Õpetaja: mis seal tuleb?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui see on automaatide arv number of jätkame.
Õpetaja: Järgmine input on Ee, siis Ee, ee,
Õpetaja: checkbox. See on nüüd siis. Ee, see
Õpetaja: sularaha. Sisse Noh, ee, siin natukene on vaja mõelda Ee, Põhimõtteliselt seal lapses komponendis on vaja terve seda. Asja.
Õpetaja: Me võime isegi seda tegelikult natukene praegult ära progeda. Ma panen lihtsalt praegult siia Mingisugused andmed. Lihtsalt Aa, teen ühe juurde.
Õpetaja: Te ei pea seda tegema. Programemise mõttes on seda Ainult, vaja. No võite praegu kaasa teha kui tahate, et ta, teeb siia, paneb koma ja teeb ühe objekti juurde, nagu
Õpetaja: et on, ee. Kaks Transaction type on ka Www.
Õpetaja: Nii me veel seda kuidagi ei kasuta. Location I sees on transaction Types, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nii, me võime juba selle asja tegelikult siit ära progeda
Õpetaja: selles suunas, et kuvatakse õigeid asju
Õpetaja: siin, siis. On ee. Ma korra vaatan see sularaha sisse. Aa, ma korra teen lihtsalt ühe juurde. Ma arvan, et seda Div I ongi. See On see div, mille sisse tuleks teha veemodel? Mitte veemodel, vaid v for et kui mul oleks siin need kaks tükki, kuidas nad välja paistavad.
Õpetaja: Ah, niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Aa, võibolla see Margin Bottom ei ole võibolla hea siin. Panna
Õpetaja: Ma korra vaatan uuesti, et kui neid oleks siin kaks tükki. Kuidas nad välja näeks?
Õpetaja: See vist oleks parem, on ju?
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: aga siin oleks tegelikult hea, et, ee, see asi oleks eraldi Tv Sees.
Õpetaja: Ee, sellepärast, et me tahame teha sellest ee, eraldi komponente.
Õpetaja: Mõtlen, ta on seal sees. Ta on div. Me tahame niikuinii. Või Tähendab, Vaata, see hoiab.
Õpetaja: Jah, ma nagu näen muret. Ma tahaks nagu öelda. Vaata, et mis mure siin on.
Õpetaja: Ma korra panen nad uuesti kokku. Vaata, et kui me võtame need niimoodi üksteisele, nad on suht lähestikku, mis meile nagu sobib.
Õpetaja: Aga mis meile ei meeldi, on see asi siin. Mis temaga on? Liiga üksteise kaelas,
Õpetaja: on ju? Näed siin väga lähedal
Õpetaja: Siis ma mõtlen ikkagi, et oleks võimalik kontrollida seda Margin Bottom It Oleks parem, kui see asi siin
Õpetaja: oleks Eraldi Divi sees. Ja me saame sinna panna. Ehk siis võta need kõik, kui tervik, et Neid on sul kokku vaja siin mingi kolm tükki või? Mis iganes on ju. Aga et, ee, põhimõtteliselt. Nüüd kõik asjad, mis tulevad siin allpool. Siis Hoia vahet.
Õpetaja: Muidugi me saame praegu kasutada ka seda võimalust. Vaata, et, ee, nad on kõik selle vormi sees ja
Õpetaja: peale seda, Okei, siin on ka võimalus. Tegelikult teistmoodi. Me saame tulla siia ülesse sellesse Tv I panna siia Class
Õpetaja: Mb, kolm et põhimõtteliselt, kui tuleb Lõpuks vastu see nupukene, et vali fail,
Õpetaja: siis ta hoiab seda. Näete, see vahe on juba siin nagu suurem.
Õpetaja: Me saame sellega seda kontrollida,
Õpetaja: Okei, see pole nii praegult tähtis. Kui te tulete järgi, te saate selle osa juurde, mis on tähtis, on nüüd aru, saada, et neid Asju peab tulema Mitu tükki vastab tõele?
Õpetaja: Palju Neid peab tulema.
Õpetaja: Kolm. Vähemalt sa ütles. See sõnum Meile kavatseb niimoodi sisse tulla.
Õpetaja: Okei, siis Ee, me peame tegema siia, mille.
Õpetaja: Et kui seda tuleb, neid, neid checkbokse tuleb dünaamiliselt. Mis on siia vaja teha Before, onju?
Õpetaja: Nii, for, Nüüd on, ee. See templeid. Kuidas see käis jääks? Lihtsalt meelde,
Õpetaja: kuidas me Vi Foori valmis teeme? Niimoodi Küsimärk, in Küsimärk
Õpetaja: paremal. Pool on Mingi kollektsioon, Mis on meie kollektsioon?
Õpetaja: Mis on meie kollektsioon? Öelge teie mulle
Õpetaja: ja täpselt, mille sees ta on.
Õpetaja: Location i sees. Ehk siis Location punkt Transaction Types. Okei,
Õpetaja: tuleme siia. Ütleme Location punkt Transaction types
Õpetaja: nüüd vasakule poole. Mingeid muuta ja nime vaja.
Õpetaja: No, kui kollektsioon on Põhimõtteliselt see siis ainsuses oleks Vist Transaction. Type on nii?
Õpetaja: See ei oleks perfekt. Me nüüd. Mis meil nüüd juurde tulime, Mis asi see, On Mis asi see on?
Õpetaja: See on sildikene.
Õpetaja: Igal igal tsüklil Selles sildi taga on päriselt üks objekt. Ee hetkel tegin siia. Juurde. Vaata et on kaks objekti. A, A ja W. W.
Õpetaja: Võibolla Paneme korra siia. Need Id ka Üks ja kaks. Näiteks onju?
Õpetaja: Midagi taolist, et Igal tsüklil. Ta võtab ühe nendest ja paneb siia.
Õpetaja: Mis see punane joon on? Mis Talle ei meeldi? Öelge tee mulle,
Õpetaja: Kui kasutad viib Foori siis on vist väike nõue.
Õpetaja: Ghee mi? Mis eesmärki see Ghee teenendab,
Õpetaja: Võrdleb mingeid asju. On päris hea, aga nüüd ütleme veel paremini, Mida ta siis võrdleb Ja miks see, mis ta eesmärk on?
Õpetaja: Ta võrdleb igal objekti juures ainult ühte väikest detaili ja vaatab, et kas on mingeid muudatusi. Kui on mingi muutus, siis ta teab. Ta peab koodi uuesti renderdama ehk. Siis ta peab uuesti.
Õpetaja: Ee, selle Html I joonistama. Ehk siis Ghee D on vaja. Ghee tuleb kuskilt muutujast. Ei hakka seda sõna Ghee veel kirjutama, enne kui
Õpetaja: panen, mille kooloni Ghee võrdub.
Õpetaja: Noh, kus objekti sees on? Siis? See väikene osa, mida ma tahan vaadata.
Õpetaja: Transaction Type Tt.
Õpetaja: Pange juba siia. Valige transaction type, aga Mitte terve objekt, vaid.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis oleks siin? Perfect kandidaat on ju? Sobib ideaalselt.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see tsükkel on korrektselt selles mõttes tehtud, et nüüd, peaks tulema siin see sularaha sisse Kaks korda,
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Kõik on hästi, aga nüüd on, ee, mõned asjad vaja korda teha. Esiteks on Lihtsalt on kõigil sularaha sisse Aga me ei soovi, et on sularaha sisse, vaid
Õpetaja: on siis need location name. Id, onju? Vabandust, sorry, Transaction Type Name Id on nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd on vaja see eesmärk saavutada.
Õpetaja: Label on meil siin, kus ma asun, tagide sees tag idest väljas atribuudi Sees, kus ma asun Tagide vahel.
Õpetaja: Kui siia saab teksti kirjutada, kuidas ma annan Poele märku? Vaata, et kuule. Ei, ei, ma ei mõtle Niimoodi,
Õpetaja: Jah, topelt. Loogilised sulud nüüd. Mis on see sildikene, millega mina soovin suhelda
Õpetaja: Mitte mitmuses.
Õpetaja: Aitäh
Õpetaja: Vastab ju tõele, et me ju tsükeldame Loome seda objekti vastavalt sellele massiivile. Location Transaction Types võtmena Me juba jälgime alam
Õpetaja: alam muutujat, Nagu et mille järgi me identifitseerime, kas on Muudatus või mitte on selle taipide Id järgi. No ega Nüüd on ju siis põhimõtteliselt vaja, et Oota, aga igal tsüklil, ma võtan selle ühe objekti ja tahan sealt seest.
Õpetaja: See See Location Transaction types on see kast.
Õpetaja: See siin on Location Transaction Type.
Õpetaja: Ilma Ita Keeruline See Oli kurat siis. Mis on see sildikene ja. Ja transaction type.
Õpetaja: Ja täpsemalt tahame siia nime. Siis ma võitan. Punkt
Õpetaja: Aa, Transaction Type Id. Noh, vaatame, mis siis on. Siis? Üks, kaks, kolm, nagu
Õpetaja: name. Muidugi Transaction Type name.
Õpetaja: No nüüd peaks tulema see A ja B, W, on nii?
Õpetaja: Oo, ei, cool. Aga nüüd on veel üks asi vaja Ära teha.
Õpetaja: See siin.
Õpetaja: Minul on praegult siin. Ee vaikimisi is, available True ja True. Ma panen ühe truuks ja teine paneks False iks.
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, et see peaks ju peegeldama nüüd seda, et mis on valitud ja mis mitte on nii,
Õpetaja: et eesmärk on selline ju, et need asjad on süngis.
Õpetaja: No, minuli on ju pandud is available, See on nagu see, et kas selles asukohas on saadaval
Õpetaja: sularaha sisse. Kas on saadaval sularaha välja? Kas on Saadaval See peab? Need peavad meie valikud olema on ju.
Õpetaja: Mis tüüpi on See input?
Õpetaja: See input on checkbox.
Õpetaja: Ühe korra oleme seda korra teinud ka. Kui tegime seda Üheksakümnendate panka. Ee, tegime seda väikest harjutust, et Kuidas ma sain kontrollida seda. Vaata, et kas on
Õpetaja: ee, niiöelda tikt või mitte, tal on Üks oma atribuut. See ei ole välju. Ma võin öelda,
Õpetaja: et kui mina panen näiteks, Ma panen pealt vaikimisi. Vaata checked
Õpetaja: nüüd kõikidel nendel dividel, mis ta siin teeb? Kõik on checked,
Õpetaja: Aga mina ei soovi, et see oleks vaid, et tema saaks hoopis väärtuse kuskilt muutujast,
Õpetaja: kus Ma tahan seda saada.
Õpetaja: Jälle. Mingit sildikest on vaja.
Õpetaja: Alustame, mis? Ma kirjutan siia.
Õpetaja: Aga miks? Location? Kas Location I küljes on? Ee, mingisugune Väärtus, mida mina otsin, ei ole jah.
Õpetaja: Mille järgi? Ma pean otsustama, Et kas siis saab või välja. Vist nagu selle järgi kus tema on?
Õpetaja: Tema on transaction types I sees. Üks objekt on Ju
Õpetaja: Praegu on ta seotud meil võtmega
Õpetaja: nii see välja polnud. Ma saan aru küll, aga lihtsalt. Küsimus on, mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Kas me vastab tõele, et me siin juba tsükeldame? Transaction types E. Iga Type I Üks objekt on seotud selle muutujaga
Õpetaja: Taipei sees. Ongi ju?
Õpetaja: See Ongi Transaction type. See on transaction. See on tervikuna transaction types üks konkreetne element ühel hetkel saab olla seotud võtmega.
Õpetaja: Vot nii saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Noh, parem. On. Ma. Ta ei oleks samal real see näiteks teisel Tsüklil on see objekt.
Õpetaja: Selline mis on muutuja mõttes?
Õpetaja: Saate aru.
Õpetaja: Me peame saama aru, mis silti me siia paneme.
Õpetaja: Kui kui sina paned praegu selle location. Väga tore. No location Tervet objekt. Ee, kuidagi rehkendu alampunktis on
Õpetaja: transaction types number. Of Siin pole mingit asja mis sobiks, Onju? Meie soovime siin ikkagi, et on punkt.
Õpetaja: Nii see veilab on.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd saab vaadata, Kui Refresh toimub.
Õpetaja: Kas see andmete sisu peegeldatakse Ootame ära elementidesse. Tundub, et nagu. On okei, onju?
Õpetaja: No päris hea, Päris hea.
Õpetaja: Mhmh,
Õpetaja: nüüd siin on üks. Asi Mis ee, vajab Timmimist mis tegelikult ei ole praegult. Ma ütlen sõna otseses mõttes. See lõpptulemus ei ole kooskõlas Html reeglitega
Õpetaja: Id kui me kasutame kuskil Aa kuskil Aa, selles,
Õpetaja: kui me kasutame kuskil, ee, niiöelda Html I sees Tag I Id, siis vähemalt sellel lehel. Ja selles konkreetses hetkes kui seda Brauser renderdab siis It peaks olema alati uni unikaalne. Ainult ühe korra ühel elemendil.
Õpetaja: Aga praegult Ju Lõpptulemusena on meil seda Div I kokku Lõpuks kolm korda
Õpetaja: ja nende kõigi Id on Transaction Type Id üks on nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd siin. Me peame tegema veits fookus puhkust
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et Me Ei, soovi, et see oleks nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma vist vajan natukene Siin on See kuramuse rõve Süntaks mida mina peast Ei, oska.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on. Esiteks on mingi väga rõve koma, mida mina ei oska kunagi Hitida. Nagu. Kus see on? Üldse pole see.
Õpetaja: Ee, teist ei ole. See ei ole. See on Tilde.
Õpetaja: Võibolla see üks nendest on. Ee. Võibolla saab. Teha. Niimoodi. Me ütleme, et saab oma väärtuse muutujast.
Õpetaja: Sellist muutujat ei ole. Me võime korra proovida. Me paneme ta üksikkülakomade vahele praegult, et see osa oleks siin String
Õpetaja: Ja Plussiga, paneme juurde Nüüd ühe muutuja. Mis on siis? Noh, mis number võiks tulla siia,
Õpetaja: et oleks unikaalne igal tsüklil?
Õpetaja: Kas võiks olla see
Õpetaja: Nii vist saab Ka tegelikult tehakse seda natuke teistsuguse sündaksiga. Pigem
Õpetaja: aga praegu pääseb nii. Kas te saate aru, et nüüd ta ütleb, et Hei, Id väärtus tuleb
Õpetaja: selline string. Vaadake, kuidas me kavalalt kasutasime. Üksikkülaka omasid ja lasket.
Õpetaja: Mõnus, et igal asjal saab olema Niukene sõna Transaction Type Id
Õpetaja: ja Ülejäänud osa. Ta võtab sellest päris muutujast.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis see lõppversioon sellest lehest siin. Kui ma teen nüüd inspekt ja vaatan elements
Õpetaja: siis ma Peaksin nägema, et see ülemine, kus see siin on?
Õpetaja: Teeme natuke laiemaks.
Õpetaja: Mis on tema Id?
Õpetaja: Transaction Type It on üks, on nii? Näete Seda siin Ma teen natuke veel laiemaks, et oleks ühel real
Õpetaja: sa teha. Aa niimoodi, saab võibolla.
Õpetaja: Mis on selle input? I Id
Õpetaja: selle Input I Id on transaction typ Id. Üks on E.
Õpetaja: Kui ma nüüd teen selle, panen kinni. Võtan selle järgmise buttoni lahti, siis tema on Transaction Type Id kaks.
Õpetaja: Nii et dünaamiliselt me lahendasime ka selle mure. Ära See on eelkõige selle Label I jaoks Vaata peaksime viitama ju elemendile on ju,
Õpetaja: et. Ee. Kui ma nüüd selle panen siit Niimoodi kinni, lähme tagasi.
Õpetaja: Siis. Selle mõte oli see, et porlabel
Õpetaja: peaks viitama sellele samale Id le, mis on siin, on nii?
Õpetaja: Siis kogu see osa. Me peaksime ütlema samamoodi. Vaata, et see foor ei saa enam stringi vaid Saad kuskilt muutujast.
Õpetaja: Ja me võtame kogu selle osa, mis on siin jutumärkidest Jutumärkideni. Näete see osa copy me
Õpetaja: ja siis Paste Ime siia asemele, et nad, mõlemad omavahel kattuvad, et sellel input Il on Transaction Type Id mingi number ja labelil siis viitab täpselt sellele samale asjale.
Õpetaja: Kuna juba läks mitmele reale, siis ma teeks niimoodi, et see label I algus on. Siin Niimoodi üleval
Õpetaja: ja natukene läks, tegi ta koledaks Niimoodi võiks olla minu meelest see asi.
Õpetaja: Ta ei mahu üle selle joone. Kas teil on see Joon kaugemal kui minul, Vaadake, umbes seda vähemalt ei ole.
Õpetaja: No, seda saaks liigutada. Aga, noh, ma ei tea. See on nagu mingi standard setting. Vaata, et kas Seda nagu mõistlik selles mõttes muudata aga. Minu arust ma nagu vanasti mäletas et, nagu ruumi oli natuke rohkem
Õpetaja: aga, ma võin eksida ka
Õpetaja: See koht on võibolla koht ka onju? Ee, siin on nii palju tehtud. Ärme lase teil jageleda Tulge lihtsalt järgi.
Õpetaja: Käsi püsti, kes kavatseb järgi tulla. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: Triin oli üksinda joonel. Vaata, nagu.
Õpetaja: No see viimane läks natuke lappesse, kuna ta automaatselt tõstis ka veel paigast ära, Vaata, Et nagu. Kuidas teil teeb? Kuidas minul teeb?
Õpetaja: Kuulge, viimane tegema.
Õpetaja: No mulle see kood. Nagu väga, väga nunnu ei ole, Nagu ma pigem tahaks Ta panna kõik ühele joonele, aga ta. Lihtsalt Vaata, kui kaugele ta läheb. Veits läheb rõvedaks.
Õpetaja: Aga võibolla see ongi hea ka tegelikult Sellepärast, et, ee. Kui te vaatate nüüd seda. Html I. No vaatame mitu rida. Meil on praegu juba koodi. Html on juba kaheksakümne ühe peal, aga asi võibolla ei olegi nagu selles.
Õpetaja: Kas te saate aru, mis siin, üljootes, Mis siin Nagu, toimub? Kui vaataks peale, kui ta Tuleks praegult siia
Õpetaja: ja vaataks seda
Õpetaja: Kas teil oleks suht kiiret pilti ees, et nagu. Mis siin Nagu toimub, mul ei ole kõik lahtigi Veel praegult, siin on ju?
Õpetaja: No mina ei tea, kuidas teil on, aga minul tõmbas küll. Nagu. Ma tulen siia lehele, siis tegelikult tõmbab silme eest kirja Oleme ausad.
Õpetaja: Esmapilgul on üsna rõve,
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas see oleks nagu erinev, kui meil oleks siin tegelikult lihtsalt üleval. Ee, heeder Lisaasukoht Meil oleks siin Ee City, Strop Town
Õpetaja: Ja meil Oleks siin ee Foorum mingi input mis, iganes
Õpetaja: ja. Siis juba tuleks sealt alt juba veel mingid komponendid. Kui meil oleks eraldi komponendid, siis tegelikult me saaksime pildi vähemalt nagu
Õpetaja: enamvähem ette ja siis saaks nagu rännata see Ongi see eesmärk?
Õpetaja: Nii, Ee, selle idee järgi saime nagu paika, et.
Õpetaja: Et andmed alla flowvad. Aa, see. Meil vist oli ka juba ära Tehtud onju, et tegelikult andmed ju flowvad, aga oli läbi, mille meil oli. Läbi Image data. Aga vaadake, kui ma praegu selle image data Teen niimoodi
Õpetaja: niimoodi. Ta näitab, kas koodis kuskil on seda veel. Kus on seda veel,
Õpetaja: et me tahaksime et andmed mitte ei ole selle Eraldi muutuja pealt vaid oleks hoopis selle pealt.
Õpetaja: Selected City Id jookseks selle City Id pealt. Saate mõtteliselt aru. Meil on veits vaja veel muudatusi teha, et me saaks need ära kaotada.
Õpetaja: No aga siis ongi vaja üles otsida, et kus need on kasutatud. Kui siia peale klikkida. Ta näitab, kus siin koodifailist on leitud. Meid Huvitab see kõige ülemine osa. Siin.
Õpetaja: See osa siin põhimõtteliselt kus on nimi Startat kasutatud ja nupu juures. Siin
Õpetaja: Kõik tuleb üles leida. Siin, Me ei taha öelda nagu see, et pilt. Vaata, et kas on pilt või ei, ole, et vaata seda
Õpetaja: selle muutuja pealt.
Õpetaja: Vaid Tahame öelda, et hoopis selle pealt. Siis Mis ma siin kirjutan?
Õpetaja: No case location punkt image data, Siin on see ära vahetatud.
Õpetaja: Kohe on nüüd see koht, et. Ee, et see on see, et kui ei ole pilti, näita seda. Seda on ju? Aga nüüd me. See on meil ära lahendatud. Aga nüüd on see, et kust nagu andmed, tulevad need hetkel endiselt, kui on Pilt võetakse selle muutuja pealt. Aga me kavatsen selle ära kasutada.
Õpetaja: Siis siia kirjutan, Ma kirjutan siia.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma teen. Ma teen selle liigutuse ära. Ma kustutan selle Cutiga ära. Nagu siis siin. Tal on mingi kollane joon all, et Kuule, millest sa jääpid, pole niukest muutujat, No ei olegi. See ongi plaan.
Õpetaja: Samamoodi on ju Location punkt Image data.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on siin see all. Vaata, kui alt tuleb pilt Event New Image Selected. Öeldakse, et image data saab selle sisu, mis sealt alt tuleb. Samamoodi ütleb, et kuule, et ei ole niukest muutujat,
Õpetaja: siis Siin Ma ütlen täpi pealt Sama location punkt.
Õpetaja: Image data.
Õpetaja: Nüüd sellest saime lahti.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tahaks sellest Selected City Id St ka lahti saada, et tegelikult City Id. Meil peaks olema seotud selle objektiga. Võibolla kõige lihtsam ongi jälle, et kustutab selle ära,
Õpetaja: sest et siis üleval hakkab Midagi nagu, võibolla helendama.
Õpetaja: No me peame sinna minema. Mul on ta kinni.
Õpetaja: Mis real? Ma pean tegema? Muudatuse?
Õpetaja: Kaks kuusteist.
Õpetaja: Jah, sinna alla Ei voola Selected City Id, vaid location Punkt City Id.
Õpetaja: Põmm. Mis iganes andmed on, seda vormil kuvatakse.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui korra Refresh ida, vaadata
Õpetaja: Sest väike säte ongi ju tegelikult Vaadake, null. Ma muudan korra selle ära. Lihtsalt millekski muuks, onju, et,
Õpetaja: ee, oleks nagu, näha, et ta Töötab,
Õpetaja: et juba Edit töötaks. Meil selles mõttes.
Õpetaja: Vot nüüd, kus meil on Niukene asi tehtud,
Õpetaja: kogu vorm on tehtud ja ta Flow igatepidi Siis nüüd on see aeg, et
Õpetaja: hakkaks lammutama. Aga teeks seda Võibolla siis peale pausi.
Õpetaja: Jah, ja ma teen kohe otsa. Ja push in sellega peale vahetundi Siis saate selle
Õpetaja: kätte. Ma panen Ee, pau, Ee, rekordi pausi. Nii et proovime meeles hoida kording.
Õpetaja: Aa, jõudsime siis nii Kaugele, kus me näeme, et vähemalt see ühe suuna Flow on ilusti. Nagu ära tehtud. Ja just ühesuunaline. On Siin see rõhuasetus, et me ei soovigi, et oleks kahesuunaline siin kontekstis. Kuna meil on plaan saada kogu sellest mudrust lahti ja teha komponendid.
Õpetaja: Ee, taaskis oli siis ee. Selle vormi osa oli location details input.
Õpetaja: Aa, kurat, las ee. Mina tahaks seda ära muuta.
Õpetaja: Pildil elama ei saa, aga siin ma mõtlen Nagu, et paneks lihtsalt. Ee,
Õpetaja: sest et ta on vorm ja selle joonise mõttes natukene kitsamalt, et see see nupp ei oleks osa vormist Vaid ainult need väljad, mida saab täita. Saate aru, et see roheline kast lõpeb siin ära, Onju
Õpetaja: Ee, No kui me vaatame, kuidas meil Need asjad on siis Aa, Tegelikult meil ongi need asjad siin. Aa, üsna kenasti
Õpetaja: selles kolumnis siin.
Õpetaja: See sama asi, mis on selle sama juures, et kui me võtame korra selle kinni,
Õpetaja: ta ei saa aegselt pandud,
Õpetaja: siis. Ee Kas siin sees on infot?
Õpetaja: Location ei, Ee, input Number of Htms.
Õpetaja: Checkbox Eid transaction. Types Sobib, aga see nupp niiöelda. Et.
Õpetaja: Oota, korra. Kus kohas on? Natukene korra segadus. Ma pean vaatama ikkagi üle.
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: image Input on täiesti eraldi, Row. Nii et klapib. Ühesõnaga, see sama div, mis meil hakkab siit realt kaheksateist
Õpetaja: võiks olla Meie Location form.
Õpetaja: Nüüd
Õpetaja: me ei ole praegu sinna juurde ühtegi niiöelda sellist interaktiivsust pannud, et klikk ja käivitub mingi meetod. Palju võimelised polegi, ühtegi meetodit siin veel Aga need meetodid valmistavad andmed. Ära. Get Cities. Ja
Õpetaja: hetkel ongi ainult City, sest kuidagi rohkemat ee me ei ole jõudnud. Progeda veel. No me teeme varsti selle ka ära.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis, aga peamine asi. On see, et nendel elementidel lendadel pole mingeid nuppe, Mis käivitaks meetodeid meil siin. Sest niipea kui hakkad seda asja tegema siis pärast, ee niiöelda komponentideks. Niiöelda ekstraktimine enam ei tule. Nii hea,
Õpetaja: Sest et viidatakse meetoditele mis on siin, tuleb nihuke kole Asi
Õpetaja: ehk siis. Teile nagu projektidesse. Ka. Vaata, ärge ennem Tähendab, proovige siis hakata mul hakka hakkama tegema, Lammutama neid Html Elemente eraldi komponentideks. Siis kui teil on nagu paigas. Teil on seal mingid andmed olemas,
Õpetaja: aga niipea kui justkui tunned, et mingil elemendil tahad panna mingeid klikke venti juurde ja mingeid meetodi käivitus, siis on nagu see, et praegu teil ei Ole õige aeg või tuleb juba teha meetodiks ära ja siis edasi toimetada. Mitte meetodiks komponendiks. Nii, Ee, tuleme. Võtame meie kogu selle rea Kaheksateist, mis on kokkuvõtvalt kaheksateist. Kuni viiskümmend kaheksa.
Õpetaja: Teeme parema kliki.
Õpetaja: Refactor Extract View komponent.
Õpetaja: Suure tähega. Kirjutame Ee location form.
Õpetaja: Vot nii oleks tegelikult Päris hea.
Õpetaja: Nüüd isegi enne kui Enter It vajutan. Või kui vajutada entrit pole midagi, siis mis me juba näeme. Vaata siit vaatest, Ta näitab, et all on selline muutuja või props nagu Location ja kaasa antakse siit datablok Ist location alla kaasa, on, nii
Õpetaja: sest et meil Siin koodi sees oli kasutatud Location It.
Õpetaja: Ma korra panen. Vaata enda vaates. Ta ei vaata seda niimoodi, et. Oot, oot, sa kasutad Kuskil name I, et annaks selle eraldi. Ta vaatab põhimõtteliselt kõige suurema objekti, mida siin, kasutatakse,
Õpetaja: et kui kuskil, kui see oleks veel mingi objekt ja mingi alam objektid. Ta võtab ikka ainult nagu, ee, põhimõtteliselt nagu selle ülemise nime.
Õpetaja: Kui meil on mingi mitmekihiline objekt,
Õpetaja: kui seal, Kui selles, ee, selles selektsioonis oleks kuskilt Cityst kasutatud ja Location Id, siis ta paneks, et noh, mõlemad lähevad alla,
Õpetaja: aga ta ei hakka vaatama niimoodi, et Oot, City S on üldse tegelikult massiiv ja midagi taolist. Ta ei hakka seda vaatama. City D. Kuskil on sul seal Koodilõigus kasutatud. Kui sul on location olemas, siis sul on olemas ka see Location City Id. Saate aru Ta võtab kõige välisema objekti, mida on seal kasutatud.
Õpetaja: Noh, teen mina uuesti sellest, et ma vajutasin. Escape
Õpetaja: Ee Factor Extractive Component ja Location Ainsuses. Form Enter.
Õpetaja: Tegime jälle kenasti selle ära. Script I pani ülesse. Templeid on all
Õpetaja: Ad. Loomulikult soovime, et see on versioneeritud failide seas.
Õpetaja: Ee, siit siis lihtsalt tõstab ära Lihtsalt Control Iks
Õpetaja: ja läheb siia template alla, lööb see mingi paar tühikut ja paneb selle Scripti alla.
Õpetaja: Ma ausõna ma ütlen, et te Võite oma projektides tegelikult täitsa mõelda, et teha script üleval ja template all. Me ei viitsi siin seda ümber teha. Ma ei näe Point I.
Õpetaja: Et ee. Aga te võite seal niimoodi teha, kui te tahate ennast harjutada. Põhimõtteliselt sellise mõttemaailma, nagu mõttemaailmaga, mida te potentsiaalselt
Õpetaja: siis ee, Kuskil töökeskkonnas näed? Näete, ma küsin ühe küsimuse. Ruttu, Chatilt ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, selline lähenemine.
Õpetaja: Et Ee, Script ta esime esimesena ja ee, templeid Teisena Selline lähenemine.
Õpetaja: Ee, selline lähenemine, et skrip I osa on üleval. Pool
Õpetaja: on kasutusel ka teistes raamistikes
Õpetaja: või poe.
Õpetaja: Vaadake ümber palju.
Õpetaja: Mida
Õpetaja: kirja, Et sa mõtled nagu õppematerjale
Õpetaja: ja. Ja saab küll. Panna. Jah, muidugi ei Vaata, mida Artur rääkis. Vaata, on see, et saad reeglite alla panna. Vaata, et, ee, kui hakkame arendama. No me pole sellest praegu rääkinud. Kuna me pole mingit arendust siin teinud. Näed seda, Cloud Md Faili.
Õpetaja: Siin on ju juhised.
Õpetaja: See fail oli useita töötamisel. Arhitektuur, Composition Api Bla blabla ja nii edasi, et siin selles mõttes saab. Väga hästi see stiili ära panna. Vaata, kuidas me soovime
Õpetaja: ta. Ta teeb neid komponente. See oli see mõte. Ma korra mõtlesin, et sa mõtlesid, et see küsimuse vastus panna. Aga vaata, mis ta ütleb. Vaata, Voe. Kolm Scripti üleval.
Õpetaja: Komponentide script Tavaliselt esimene. Seejärel markup Distyle. Ühesõnaga sarnane Filosoofia eraldi failid. Ahah, okei. Aa
Õpetaja: Vastand, Läheb neid templeid üleval. Mõned woearendajad helistavad templit. Esimene, sest vaatan kõigepealt, mida komponent kuvab soo rohkem Disainer First mõtteviis.
Õpetaja: Ee, mida ta ära ei maininud Siin on nagu React. Nagu aga React. Ma tegelt seda tahtsingi teada.
Õpetaja: Reaktor on erinev, Sest seal pole eraldi skripte templeid, blokke. Kogu komponent on üks. Oi, Issand, kuidas ma vist ei tahaks seda tehagi Sellepärast,
Õpetaja: Uhh, jah, okei, Seal on teistsugune lähenemine. Ee, jah, okei,
Õpetaja: et. Ee. Põhimõtteliselt. Ee.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt võib öelda siis seda, et kas ta, ütles et Svelte vist oli Siis uus. Ee, ka. Niukene vist. Hästi lihtne nagu? Või nagu kuidagi, peaks mõttes olema. Kuidas need asjad on tulnud? Nagu. Vaata, et Ee Angular on ee
Õpetaja: üldse tehtud Ee, Google poolt. Vot siin. Ta ütleb, et seal on täiesti eraldi. Failid on eraldi ja on eraldi, et Css.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ja siis ta, siis Kui tuli Angular Angular oli Google oma tegid nemad seda asja. Siis tuli Ee Facebook või meta tuli oma reaktiga.
Õpetaja: Ja siis tuli poeg. Kuidas voe? Kolm sündis poe kolme. Põhimõtteliselt siis. Ee. Lõi Ee.
Õpetaja: Sellise lahenduse Lõi siis Ee Google töötaja
Õpetaja: Koolitöötaja hakkas siis kas siis reakti tahtma? Lihtsamalt teha või angulari? Vahet pole, mis moodi ta mõtles
Õpetaja: Sa Alguses hakkas tegema mingeid oma mingeid klotse ja asju oma lähenemist. Ja siis sai aru. Vaata, et ee, et tegelikult võiks teha täiesti eraldi uue raamistiku, et tema eesmärk oli siis teha asju võimalikult lihtsaks nagu kõikide raamistiku eesmärk on teha lihtsaks toetavaks lühikeseks.
Õpetaja: Ee, et voe voe. Kolm kindlasti võrreldes reaktiga või voe üldse on lihtsam Algajale
Õpetaja: Lõppkokkuvõttes oskad ühte Ja lõpuks õpid teise ka ära. Vahet pole.
Õpetaja: Ee, selles mõttes. Ee. Ja svelt, et, noh, Sveltega Ma isiklikult pole kokku kuidagi puutunud. Ee, kõige vähemalgi määral. Aga olen kuulnud ka, et see vist pidi olema üsna nagu Niukene mõnus,
Õpetaja: aga jõudis veel pika Natuke tagasi. Vaata. Siis tegelikult, tundub et suht See abi on ikkagi, et. Ee, et kui ma ükskord me küsisime, siis Ta oli natukene kuidagi rangem oli, aga nüüd ta juba ise. Nagu hakkas rääkima sellest ka, et
Õpetaja: tag üleval on Niukene disainer ja et Mõned nagu mõned mõndadele. See meeldib, et igal juhul jätan kõik teile lahtiseks. Tehke, kuidas tahate.
Õpetaja: See on teie projekt. Vaata, nagu, et ma ei tule teile ette dikteerima seda, et kuidas teha ainuke, asi, mis ma teile ette dikteerin, on see, et kasutage seda sama lähenemist, see Need blokid, data ja
Õpetaja: meetod. See kõik see. Vaata seda, te olete. Kui te hakkate Mixima Match ima, te võite saada raskustesse ja kui te koodi ei loe. Teil on nagu raske aru saada, et sellel ei ole pointi ja proovida midagi praegu juurde õppida, Kodus võite teha ka hakata vaatama, et. Okei, kuidas sa
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt kogu projekti peale saab? Võibolla anda saab anda käsu, et Hei, siin on kasutusel Options api Lähenemine Converti. Kogu minu projekt Composition Api S,
Õpetaja: et ta teeb nagu selle kirjaviisi kõik ümber teistsuguseks. Siis õppida, kuidas see käib,
Õpetaja: kellel huvi on Sellel ei ole. Ma ütlen, et ennem ei ole ka tegelikult vajadust. Ei Tea, kuhu te satute ja mida te tegema hakkate,
Õpetaja: et Minu eesmärk, minu soovitus teile on tegelikult kui te nüüd tagasi peale seda koolitust. Ee, niiöelda ukse sulgete ee Enda Selja taga siis, noh. Kõike ei saa muidugi seda sulgeda. Me võime kordamööda kõik käe Niimoodi Paneb ukse kinni sa. Tunne vaata. Sulged, Ukse, oma selja taga. On Väga meeldiv, alati.
Õpetaja: Mingi uus seiklus on ootamas.
Õpetaja: Et siis minu peamine soovitus oleks tegelikult proovida ikkagi hästi selgeks õppida kõik need asjad, mida Me Siin õppisime,
Õpetaja: et kinnistada need. Need ei ole neil teil kindlasti päris selged selleks hetkeks kui te, siit ära lähete, et õudsalt oleks veel vaja harjutada ja proovida ja teha, et, ee, parem parem. Kõik need konseptsioonid pähe nagu
Õpetaja: saada nagu selgeks ja ja alles siis hakata vaatama. Edasi. Ja kui te kuskile saate praktikale või tööle, siis on niimoodi, et ärge keskenduge ühelegi muule tehnoloogiale või asjale,
Õpetaja: kui vaid need Mis on tööl, et igasuguseid põnevaid asju tulevad välja igast põnevaid uudise nupid Kui sa. Loed igast igast ägedaid asju, on, aga kui te Lähete kuskile tööle, siis ärge tegelege kõrvaliste asjadega. Nagu selles mõttes, et kui teil on vaba aeg, et midagi uurida,
Õpetaja: saage profiks nendes asjades, mis Te tööl kasutate?
Õpetaja: Ee, saate kiiremini palka juurde küsida ja lihtsalt ee Jääte kindlamini tööle. Ka Pange sinna kogu Power. Nii,
Õpetaja: see Location Form on nüüd tehtud, mis on põhimõtteliselt see. Me saame kohe proovida ka, et kas midagi katki, läks et selles mõttes et kui ma Teen refresh.
Õpetaja: Tundub, et kõik läheb niiöelda alla. Ilusti välja, on ju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd? Võibolla ennem, kui me liigume edasi nagu mingisuguste
Õpetaja: alamklotsidega võiks praegult teha ära ühe kett teenuse.
Õpetaja: See location I sees peab olema transaction types,
Õpetaja: et, ee. Peaks tooma ära need andmed päriselt niiöelda. Noh, hetkel siis need sisud.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on üks väikene probleem.
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele? Aa, okei praegult. Isegi mitte nii väga. Hetkel lisamisel on vist ülisavi
Õpetaja: Hetkel kuskil Seda Location sisu Ei, ei tule. On ju location Sisu hetkel. Meil on ainult Cities
Õpetaja: ja Get Location Id. Me hetkel ei Too ära, Kuna pole Edit olukord tulevikus. Kui me saabume siia niimoodi Location Id kaksteist. Siis peab ee, konkreetse Location I andmed tooma ära, et neid siin kuvada,
Õpetaja: siis hetkel meil praegu probleemi pole. Aga hiljem tuleme selle jutu juurde tagasi. Praegult on meil lihtsalt plaan tuua ära Need andmed,
Õpetaja: Transaction types andmed, kõik võimalikud variandid. Mis meil süsteemis on?
Õpetaja: Sest et see on lisamine lisaasukoht, Kui täna on siin sularaha sisse sularaha väljamaksed. Ja homme on andmebaasis juures Bitcoin. Siis kui me tuleme siia lehele, siis tahaks Bitcoini ka näha, et kui Lisa on mingi automaat ette, et saab Bitcoini määrata.
Õpetaja: Okei, Cool Ee. Millest alustame? Kui me räägime mingisugustest asjade ära toomisest.
Õpetaja: Noh, Even, tavaliselt on alati hüüdnud Selle sõna, Svager, et teisisõnu meie
Õpetaja: meie piibel, mille järgi me elame ja juhindume Sväger editoris. Ee, teeme lahti. Taskis, on See ka kirjeldus Olemas Kenasti
Õpetaja: Transaction types Andmed tuuakse ära Transaction Types teenusega Kett teenus. Too andmeid
Õpetaja: ja see toob umbes niukse asja.
Õpetaja: No siis me otsime sellest väge reditorist ülesse
Õpetaja: Kus ta on meil siin
Õpetaja: pigem enne post I peale. Pausti on But I
Õpetaja: on see, et tagastab kõikvõimalikud pangaautomaadi Teenused on selline asi mida me soovime.
Õpetaja: No siis me meie keskendume. Esialgu Sellele sõnumi saatmisele on hull. Kas parameetreid on
Õpetaja: okei nüüd responsiga Me Juba tegelikult. Ma kordan suuremaks Ma juba ee. Ei tee järgi. Kas see mudel on meil kuskil olemas või kuhu need andmed peaks minema,
Õpetaja: kui koera rääkida, et kuhu need andmed peavad minema, on kuhu nad peaksid minema?
Õpetaja: Noh, see sama valik. Vaata, Location I sisse transaction Types, et siia Nad peavad minema. Meil tegelikult põhimõtteliselt kõik asjad olemas, et ainult nagu hakkame progema, onju?
Õpetaja: Okei, Ee, paneme siis selle siia vasakule poole. Ta ei jääks siia ette Ikkagi niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, vasakule poole. Seda natukene. Kukkusin nii palju, kui lubab. Vanasti lubas täitsa peitu panna.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja teada põhimõtteliselt seda urli ketti. Ja me teame, parameetreid pole.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Aa, küsimus on siis, kus me nüüd progema hakkame? Mis Me teeme, millest võiks alustada.
Õpetaja: Uus meetod. Kuhu No Davai teeme?
Õpetaja: Uus meetod. Minul on hetkel siin. Kokku tõmmatud. Meil on siin Get Citys Respons. Noh, paneme siis siia alla meetodi. Mis siis selle meetodi nimi võiks olla?
Õpetaja: Ma saaksin.
Õpetaja: No peaaegu. Ma ei kuulnud viimast tähtava, aga Ma eeldan sa ütlesid käid Transaction Type.
Õpetaja: Seal võib isegi copida sealt, aga võib ka kirjutada Get transaction types, sest et meil on plaanis Tuua ära. Transaction types on I.
Õpetaja: No kui tahaks. Kui tahaks natukene pikemalt panna, mis on isegi täitsa kaalutuskoht,
Õpetaja: siis võibolla võiks siia kirjutada ju lausa niimoodi, et me viitame
Õpetaja: Location transaction types, et me viitame kõigepealt objektile Location
Õpetaja: Transaction types. Ma pigem teekski niimoodi
Õpetaja: siin juhul, ma Nagu ütlen, et ee, lühem ei ole parem, vaid, ee. Täpsem on parem.
Õpetaja: Okei, no ma olen see uusarendaja, mis nüüd edasi?
Õpetaja: No võibolla võiks alustada sellest, et
Õpetaja: mis siin võib olla väike vihje meil siin praegu.
Õpetaja: Mis vihje siin? On?
Õpetaja: Sa pole aktiivne. See tähendab seda, et
Õpetaja: Keegi mind ei taha, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga keegi ikka võistleda tahti, kes teda võiks tahta välja kutsuda?
Õpetaja: No kui tuleme, tuleme siia lehele.
Õpetaja: Det Törne ei ole vajalik.
Õpetaja: Pigem küsimus on see. Vaata, et millal on vaja tuua. Ära neid andmeid Get Allocation Transaction types.
Õpetaja: Kes on viimane No location View Täpsemalt.
Õpetaja: Noh, eesmärk on tuua ära. Neid andmeid on nii?
Õpetaja: Keegi mind ei taha. Kes kes tahab mind välja kutsuda, kes Kutsub mind välja.
Õpetaja: Kuidas, miks, et Nagu mul on? Nagu et vali mis tahes linn. Vali mis tahes. Ee, teenus, et kas selles kohas on olemas. Kuidas see on linnaga seotud või üldse millegiga seotud.
Õpetaja: See on uue asukoha lisamine. Siin peavad olema kõikvõimalikud teenused, mis selles mitte selles asukohas, vaid mis üldse süsteemis me oleme ära määranud.
Õpetaja: Saab valida, kui ma lisan asukoha. No teeme, mängime läbi Tallinn, Paneme mingi väikse koha. Paneme pärnu väikse koha. No pärnu, pärnu. Mingi mingi putka taga.
Õpetaja: Mingi putka taga.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen, et selle, automaat ongi üks ja nüüd Ma tahan valida, et seal, et on. Ainult valikud on sulle. Ära sisse sulle ära välja maksed, Bitcoin. Mina tahan lihtsalt valida neist ühe Vaata aga valikutes peavad olema kõik, ju on nii?
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, kui ma sellele lehele saabun, ma tahan näha kõike valikuid, olenemata, kas On mingi putka või? See on mingi keskus.
Õpetaja: Jah. Õige Samamoodi nagu linnaandmed tuuakse lehte laadides ennem. Ära
Õpetaja: siis siia, tahaks samamoodi öelda, et Aga toome ära ka.
Õpetaja: Gate Location Transaction types, on nii?
Õpetaja: Tuleb ära tuua.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui te kuidagi see aitaks, siis võiks isegi
Õpetaja: siin võiks olla isegi niuke sõna nagu all nagu onju Get all location the transaction types.
Õpetaja: Aga seda pole. Vaja see pole mingit kitsendavat parameetrit. See Võibki eeldada, et tuuakse kõik ära.
Õpetaja: No nüüd, keegi tahab. Vähemalt on nii super
Õpetaja: meile järgida nagu Miks ta lilla vaatab, Miks ta seda värvivalikut teeb. Nagu ma ei ole aru saanud. Kord on lille. Kord On
Õpetaja: Võibolla, et saab olema mingit sisu või, Ja jah,
Õpetaja: aga võibolla Siis kui siin. Ee tuuakse päriselt andmed. Ja ta on Asünkroonne Ühel. Hetkel
Õpetaja: on juba sinine. See siin. Aa, no okei, seda enam
Õpetaja: Ee Ja värvivahed. Ülikama idavärk. Vaata, tema värvib. Nad võiks olla kõik valged ka. No päeva lõpuks ju Ära unustage ära,
Õpetaja: päeva lõpuks,
Õpetaja: päeva lõpuks See tekst on. Meil
Õpetaja: mõtleb ikka täna.
Õpetaja: Mida sa mõtled? Ära kooma nii välja.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: mis tuli? Pole ammu restarti teinud ja ei taha teha ka praegu. Hetkel on see mingi. Chatid on pooleli.
Õpetaja: Ma sain ee, selle sama faili lahti. Mis värvi on tekst
Õpetaja: Päeva lõpuks sellel Värvil ei ole mitte mingisugust tähtsust. Idea ainult üritab meile midagi. Nagu kood on kood. Noh, kadus. Hiir ka ära.
Õpetaja: Küll oli suur asi, Mida lahti ikka teha? Tekstifail.
Õpetaja: Okei, ennast ära.
Õpetaja: Et, ee, selles mõttes kod on õige.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Get location transaction types. Ma tegin ära siis Selle meetodi käivitatakse ka hetkel. Lihtsalt ei ole nagu mingit sisulist action It.
Õpetaja: Mis nüüd edasi Väidake teie mind. Mina ei tea, mis kuidas Uus Api service. No mõtleme seda asja.
Õpetaja: Eus Api service.
Õpetaja: Kas päris uus api service? Või?
Õpetaja: Võibolla
Õpetaja: sobib kuhugi ka juba see Võibolla sa Mõtlesid sedasama, onju? Aga uut uut nagu ei soovi, et meil ju Locationiga on oma service Get
Õpetaja: atm Locations, aga meil ei, ole locations,
Õpetaja: Sul on ikkagi õigus location I sisse. Me toome küll, aga tegelikult me toome ju transaction type, onju?
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame seda Ee, piiblit
Õpetaja: Get Atm Transaction pole siin. Location is haisugi, onju? Pigem on see transaction types või Atm transaction types. Mis iganes,
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes sul on täiesti õigus. Ongi vaja uut. Mis läheb selle asja nimeks?
Õpetaja: Ma paneks Ee transaction. Ma panen ainsuses. Vaata, teised on ka kui lihtsalt Lisad ühe Transaction Type I. Äkki teeme niukse vormi
Õpetaja: Ee adminile.
Õpetaja: Mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Export Effort. Miks ma kirjutan? Jah,
Õpetaja: et seda saaks. Mujal kasutada et Seda, saaks importida mujal, Et soovin kasutada seda. Siis on vaja importida. Saaks midagi importida? On vaja, seda eksportida
Õpetaja: ei ole niimoodi, et et, ee. Ütleme niimoodi. O, importime Hiinast mingisugust staffi. Vaata. Aga Hiina. Mitte midagi. Ei Ekspordi,
Õpetaja: et nagu nemad peavad eksportima, et Meie saaks midagi importida, eksole?
Õpetaja: See on küll, aitäh.
Õpetaja: Jah, mustrit mis? Me oleme varem teinud, et
Õpetaja: ütleme niimoodi? Ta ei tee tingimata niukse sellega. See on minu enda välja mõeldud nagu konventsioon. See on hästi tehniline minu jaoks.
Õpetaja: Get.
Õpetaja: Ee, Tahtsin juba panna Atm, aga ei pane Seda types
Õpetaja: ja tegemist on sõnumiga Request. Mind selline asi kõnetab. Mulle meeldib nii
Õpetaja: minu tiimis. Inimesed, kes töötavad. Ee, ütlen, et mina arhitektuuri otsustanud. Mulle meeldib nii.
Õpetaja: Või Oleme tiibiga otsustanud. Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: mis nüüd siin edasi, siis et see on nüüd lihtsalt meetod
Õpetaja: mis edasi, mis ma siia sisse kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Ära panna, et lõpuks ta peab tagastama just seda vastust Ka aktsias on see tehnoloogia, kes Ee, sõnumeid saadab
Õpetaja: läbi
Õpetaja: No mis on kolm järgmist tähte, mida võiks kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Jah, kett, onju? Kett, meetod tab.
Õpetaja: Tema ootab. Sisse Control B.
Õpetaja: Mitut muutujat ootab siis Ee, mhmh.
Õpetaja: Aga mis nad on? Mida ta ootab sisse? Nüüd me juba mõtleme nagu põhimõtteliselt nendele nimedele. Mida me siin näeme, on ju
Õpetaja: Urlija siis mingisuguseid sätteid.
Õpetaja: Mis selle Mis teema selle sätetega oli Seal üks väike konks, valikuline.
Õpetaja: Kas siin on meil mingeid säteid vaja kaasa anda.
Õpetaja: Millal me. Meil on vaja sätteid kaasa anda? Siiamaani,
Õpetaja: kui saadame mida?
Õpetaja: Millal me oleme kasutanud Sätteid seda konfi hetkel ei lähe vaja. Meil on parameetreid. Parameetritest saab mõnusalt panna. Asju Panime ka headerit, onju? Näiteks, No siin ta annab. Kõik need tulemused siin. Meil mingit parameetreid Pole stop. Lightil pole ka midagi öelda. Lihtsalt iga kord annabki kõik
Õpetaja: nii. Nagu päris Back end teenuski, lihtsalt annab kõik need, mis on, On ju me juba ette teame, et meil piisab siin. Seekord. Ühest poolest
Õpetaja: on vaja ainult ära siia defineerida. Su Url.
Õpetaja: Seda saab isegi Copida, Jah,
Õpetaja: või mis puudutab selle sõnumi saatmise osas. Kas on veel midagi,
Õpetaja: Sest Ei, ei olegi, on ju? Noh, tavaliselt ongi alati olnud Ainult kaks asja on ju, et Urlja mingeid parameetreid. Parameetreid pole ju? Siis vist on nagu Done on ju?
Õpetaja: Ahaa, nüüd, küsi kes sa Jõudsid vaadata seda videomaterjali ära? No vaatame, tegelikult. Ee. Palusin silmad alla panna.
Õpetaja: Carvage Collector.
Õpetaja: Kas see video enamvähem rääkis teile ära? Whats the Story. Teate, kuidas Carbidge kollektor töötab?
Õpetaja: Suures pildis küll onju?
Õpetaja: Noh, teda juba teate. Rohkem kui mõni ülikooli tudeng võin öelda,
Õpetaja: kuidagi ei tule Nagu sa seal nagu nii põhjalikult ei õpi mingil põhjusel. Tegelikult peaks õppima Nii,
Õpetaja: miks see return on vajalik?
Õpetaja: Mis selle tööle on Vajalik siin. Miks see, Miks see vajalik? Lihtsalt kui ma ütleks, kui jaava ja kärbeks elekter.
Õpetaja: Kui sulle tööri ei ole, mis juhtub, kadun see Objekt läheb kaduma,
Õpetaja: et keegi enam talle ei viita.
Õpetaja: Keegi teda enam ei taha. Niipea kui see näeb siin vaeva,
Õpetaja: mis võiks olla selle Selle osa palve meetodi palve Prooviks. Oma sõnadega öelda.
Õpetaja: Kui sa kutsud välja mingi meetodi, mis midagi tagastab. Mingit infot
Õpetaja: Soovid sellega midagi edasi teha Pane muutujasse. Pika sammuga võiks muutujasse panna. Aga me nagu returnime Selle Kohe siis pole muutujat mõtet luua, vaid on. Seda kutsutakse. Siin on justkui muutuja. Aga see on selle rea sees.
Õpetaja: Seda return itakse, kui seda ei tee.
Õpetaja: See objekt. Isegi süsteemi tekitatakse hetkeks,
Õpetaja: aga ta ei ole seotud Mitte ühegi muutujaga. Järelikult karbiskollektor sööks ta justkui ära.
Õpetaja: No meil ei, ole niukest asja nagu aga jaos on,
Õpetaja: kui nüüd See on tehtud, Siis on väga tore. Mida see hall annab? Märku.
Õpetaja: Keegi mind ei taha, aga ikka keegi tahab.
Õpetaja: Kasuta mind, Kasuta mind ära.
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab kasutada ära midagi, mis elab kuskil mujal Failis,
Õpetaja: Jah, viitame selle failile. No, siin võiks lausa öeldes ka nagu mingi komponent Mis iganes teil on ju komponent on ikkagi, või? Noh, vabandust,
Õpetaja: mis selle faili nimi on?
Õpetaja: Mis tähed? Paneme selle Suured tähed, kolm tähta Transaction Type Service.
Õpetaja: Miks on siin tähtis? Aa, praegu vajutada? Tab I, mis juhtub taustal.
Õpetaja: Import tekib ülesse.
Õpetaja: Nüüd praegu katsun justkui seda faili Kuidas saan käivitada seal sees meetodeid mõttes punkti abil.
Õpetaja: Noh, mängi meetodeid. Tema annab mulle mingi objekti.
Õpetaja: Kogu see asi nüüd rehkendub objektiks. Objektidel On olemas meetodid, mida saab käivitada niimoodi. Jaavas on ka. Me käivitame objekti meetodeid. Kogu aeg
Õpetaja: See osa annab objekti nüüd meie ees tehnoloogia Ise saab käivitada ühe või teise meetodi. Näiteks ten.
Õpetaja: Näiteks saab käivitada. Catch.
Õpetaja: Näiteks saab käivitada Finally.
Õpetaja: Me tahame. Hakkab koodi Tulema. Juba, Praegu Pole midagi kirjutada. Ega See piir vist väga kaugel pole. See selle asjaga siin, eksole?
Õpetaja: Tavaliselt niisuguse. Kui tahad kuskil lüüa uuele reale, siis Tavaliselt enne punkti lüüakse, valitakse mingi sobiv koht.
Õpetaja: Kuidas trenn käitub?
Õpetaja: Kuidas Catch käitub? Mis, Mis nende vahe on, Kui läheb kõik hästi,
Õpetaja: teil Läheb kõik hästi. Räägime hästi korraks. Tehniliselt ka vastus on õige. Ma ei tea.
Õpetaja: Htp status. Code, Vaata, et igaüks saad sõnumi, su teine Pool vastab sulle ka staatusega.
Õpetaja: Kõik kahesajaga on need läheks hästi
Õpetaja: Nelisada. Viissada on halvasti. Millal Käitub see, kui on kakssada midagi. Millal käitub See
Õpetaja: nelisada või viissada midagi. Millal see käivitub?
Õpetaja: Peale Peale embakumba, onju?
Õpetaja: Süntaks. Siin sees saab teha Action It
Õpetaja: aga meil on kõigepealt saada vaja vastust kätte saada, siis mis? Meil on siin kõigepealt vaja, et üldse selle objektiga suhelda. Mis tuleb
Õpetaja: silti
Õpetaja: kuskilt. Juba tuli silti. See on silt. Nüüd tahaks teha Action It. Siin on Lambda Lambo funktsioon. Niukene konventsioon Nool funktsioon. See Nüüd ütleb, et võrdusmärgiga on see noolekene Teeme Action It
Õpetaja: pissiga. Ei ole midagi praegult teha Või tegelikult saaks ka. Aa, sest mõtleme korra. Mis need tegevused on, Mis meil, mis On see tegevus, mis peab juhtuma? Me toome andmeid ära.
Õpetaja: Me oleme teinud City Service I puhul. Vaata, on ee, handel response
Õpetaja: ja tegelikult, Kui me vaatame, mis see kogu sisu oneliner,
Õpetaja: me saaksime seda teha Inline ka. Ma pakun, et me. Ma ei tea, kas me teeme Või Ei tee. Ee, kui see sisu ongi niivõrd lihtne
Õpetaja: Ainult üks koodirida.
Õpetaja: See on praegu siin ongi. Tehke korraga. Otsige ülesse. Need read.
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, et kui mina võtaks need koodiread ja paneksin selle meetodi asemele, siis tegevus on see sama,
Õpetaja: kui seda saab ühel real ära teha, See on see sama. Mäletate, kui me teeme mit iga niimoodi kuskil komponendi sees? Vaata, onju Ja Html i sees Teeme
Õpetaja: mingi Mingi event on.
Õpetaja: Palun mitte ülesanne Aga mingi tulemus, et ma, arvan et sellel meetodil,
Õpetaja: kui sa siit niimoodi ära võtta, et ei ole suuresti. Oota, kas ta. Miks ta nüüd ära ei kadunud?
Õpetaja: Et oota Erroriga. Ee, kus. Kui toimub mingi mitu tegevust, siis on see võibolla Vajalik,
Õpetaja: mis ta endiselt viitab Sellele See on juba kadunud. Siit juba tegelikult ütleb, et ei ole seal. Saab ära kustutada, on ju?
Õpetaja: Kas Saate aru, nagu millal seda teha ja millal mitte teha.
Õpetaja: Kui see asi läheks juba üle mitme rea,
Õpetaja: Noh, siis saaks seda ka väga edukalt teha Pole probleemi. Võtan korra selle Control X Panen siia.
Õpetaja: Noh, kirjuta üle mitme rea koodi, kui tahad, aga siis see rikub ja risustab meie mõtlemist.
Õpetaja: Siin ei ole midagi eriti. Handl Ida. Lihtsalt Cities saab endale uue sisu, nii et siin oleks parem teha nii ja Tegelikult, siin. Selles on samamoodi. Me tahame lihtsalt seda sisu. Aga meil midagi muud ei tule. Hetkel
Õpetaja: ei ole ju mingeid muid tegevusi ei Ole mingi sa midagi ei Salvesta mingeid If e kuskile. Ei Vaata,
Õpetaja: kui me ütleme, et Get Location Transaction types, siis mis me siin teeme.
Õpetaja: Noh, ees meetod ise ütleb. Vaata ju ära ju.
Õpetaja: Noh, see tegevus ongi ju siis see, et mis ma siin kirjutan, this mis Ma nüüd kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Kettekirjuta. Mis ma siin kettekirjutan? Käivitan seda sama meetodit uuesti, vä? Ee, teeme jälle rekursiooni. Tuled siia sisse, Saan õnneliku vastuse, Käivitan uuesti, tulen sisse,
Õpetaja: Mis see eesmärk on?
Õpetaja: Eesmärk on, et selline asi saaks. Sisu on ju?
Õpetaja: Sellepärast ma paningi selle location i juurde, Vaata, et et oleks täpne. Vaata, et Hei
Õpetaja: Location I Transaction types vist tahab saada mingit sisu.
Õpetaja: See, et me panime siia kaks elementi, A, B või B. See on jama. Ju see on siin. Peaks mudel olema. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: mis? Teeme siin?
Õpetaja: Ändå?
Õpetaja: Jah, näed, ütleme, puudutame Location It.
Õpetaja: Sealt seest Puudutame Transaction Typesi.
Õpetaja: Me tahame öelda, et tema saab. See on puudutamine, kui tahaks andmeid lugeda. Me tahame öelda, et Kuule, saa mingi sisu, mis ma kirjutan, siis ees
Õpetaja: võrdub. Märkan ja
Õpetaja: nüüd võiks öelda. Respons on nüüd see objekt, millega me saame suhelda, aga Selle objekti sees on mitmed asjad. Meid meid huvitab ainult see respons Body, mille me saame siis kätte?
Õpetaja: Kuidas data meid ei huvita status Quot Siin meid. Ei huvita mitte mingi muu asi meid. Huvitab ainult
Õpetaja: Meid Huvitab üksi ainukene. Asi. On see sisu me. Tahame seda
Õpetaja: ma. Mäletad seda pilti? Mul vist. Aa, ma ei hakka seda lahti tegema. Kogu see asi respons
Õpetaja: seal sees on erinevat infot. Nii headerid, status, Koodid, status, tekstid, Seda osa.
Õpetaja: See osa seal objektis on. On Data võtmes punkt. Data, anna kätte.
Õpetaja: Kõik Meil ei ole ühtegi defineeritud Viga. Siin, aga võib tulla alati
Õpetaja: See, et Ups, midagi läks valesti.
Õpetaja: Sellisel juhul me siiamaani oleme alati lihtsalt öelnud, et. Kuule, mine.
Õpetaja: Ups, midagi Ei, läks valesti. Meil ei ole mõtet, nagu siin näiteks on. Meil ei ole mõtet seda vastust mingisuguse sildiga siduda, sest et meil ei Ole sellega midagi teha siin selles olukorras kontekstis. Siis me tahame siin samamoodi Catch is teha. Et Kuule, anonüümselt teed niimoodi sulud ja paned Noolfunktsiooni.
Õpetaja: Käivita mingi tegevus.
Õpetaja: Navigation Service punkt Navigate To Error View
Õpetaja: Finalis. Mitte Midagi ei ole teha, aga las ta olla praegu siin Algorajal. Koristame nüüd kunagi. Ära. Vot seda saab mõelda ka veel hiljem
Õpetaja: las ta olla käivitub. Aga seal sees ei ole mingit sisu, et päris Elus koristaks selle ära, kui seal mingit sisu ei tule. Aga las ta olla praegu.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ta olla?
Õpetaja: Saame alati seda juurde teha, aga Las ta olla praegu. Vähemalt sunnib mõtlema mingi hetk.
Õpetaja: No nüüd on siis see, et enam ei ole pointi. Nagu sellel Transaction Typesil siin, Ee,
Õpetaja: ee. Päris näidisandmetega. Vaid teeme, et on mudel, et on mingi number on mingi tekst
Õpetaja: ja pigem nad nad praegu tulevad, kõik False Ina. Näete, siis ma pigem paneks. Siia konkreetselt ikkagi false.
Õpetaja: Et No vaikimisi. Nagu tuleb False Ina Niikuinii see sisu nüüd kirjutatakse üle.
Õpetaja: Ei, No üldse, võime proovida. Kas see asi töötab?
Õpetaja: Noh, mingi asi on jama. Vaata nüüd peab hakkama vaatama, et, ee, siia ei kuvata midagi, Ei, tule neid.
Õpetaja: Siis tuleb mõelda, et Ee, kus on midagi valesti.
Õpetaja: Kuidas teie Teebugiksite? Kuidas me hakkaksime üldse midagi praegu vaatama? Mis mõtteid on Mida võiks vaadata,
Õpetaja: kui meil on ära progetud, et ee, käivita. Get Location Transaction Times käivitatakse, On ju?
Õpetaja: Ah, konsooli.
Õpetaja: No tegelikult võiks
Õpetaja: Okei, konsool on nüüd täiesti eraldi. Konsool Kas tuleb? Mingeid vigu? Vigu otseselt Ei, tule. Refresh iga
Õpetaja: siis kui midagi oleks siin punane kui Ta võiks siit vaadata nendest tööriistadest. Vaatame, kas üldse sõnum läheb.
Õpetaja: Viissada Stoplight kukub pikali.
Õpetaja: No siis tuleb hakata uurima. Vaata, et see sõnum Läheb Api Atm Transaction Types Sõnum Justkui läheb.
Õpetaja: Aa, Mida siis võib viga olla? No Peab vaatama korra. Äkki mul on, midagi
Õpetaja: aga teenus on selle pealt võetud.
Õpetaja: Getsõnum läks
Õpetaja: Transaction types. Sõnum suunatakse edasi. Ma korra lihtsalt teen Refresh I veel, nagu ma ei ole nagu. Kas tõesti kukub midagi valesti.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: mis nüüd oli? Nende enda mingi jama oli lihtsalt. Võibolla väga paljud. Refresh. Isime korraga ka. Kas andmed tulid
Õpetaja: tulid. Tekst on natukene siin keskel. Saaks seda Csiga öelda, et hoiaks vasakule. Ei viitsi seda teha. Savi
Õpetaja: aga töötab selles mõttes, et tuleb siia selle sõnumi pealt
Õpetaja: või? No vaadata kas kui voest? Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: poest. Võtan lahti Location View ja vaatan data blokist Location
Õpetaja: kas on transaction types olemas. Objektid
Õpetaja: on, on ju? Joonistab selle pealt.
Õpetaja: Joonistab? Tundub, et kõik on hästi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd võiks selle location Võiks natuke andmed ka korda, teha, et see location name niimoodi ei näita nii.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on Niukene hea koht, kus võibolla vahepeal kummiit teha, et mingi asi töötas päriselus, siis paneks ka mingisuguse.
Õpetaja: Ee, Vähe parema sisu kui Work in progress. Kaheksa. Mina teen kogu aeg. Kui mitte Nüüd üldse. Teen kogu aeg, Cloud. Iga Cloud Il on instrueeritud, et vaata lihtsalt nagu Tiff. Ide pealt.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis need muudatused on ja ise nagu kirjelda eesti keeles.
Õpetaja: Pane siia, et mis Mis muudatused süsteemis oli?
Õpetaja: Ee, ennem lasen tal ära valida. Ütlen, ka et lihtsalt kuva mulle neid ja siis Siis ma nagu all mul kuskil.
Õpetaja: Aga mis ta näind ikka veel siin? Vä?
Õpetaja: Ee, et ta teeb mingisuguse sisu ära ja vaatan korra, et mis Ta paneb sinna message isse ja ütlen, et sobib või ei sobi. Ja ongi kõik,
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes see oleks ikka väga Lahja on ju
Õpetaja: pärast. Kujutad tagasi Nagu otsida mingit Step i kust nagu teed seal mingit ee, arendust.
Õpetaja: Tahad minna nagu mingi paar sammu, tagasi. Nagu iga messengsi juures on mingi working progress. Nagu vist keeruline. Sa Pead hakkama klõpsima ja Vaatama. Et noh, mis sa lisasid ja Mis sa muutsid, et leida seda õiget kohta?
Õpetaja: Jeerum Jeerum.
Õpetaja: Okei, senikaua kuni Ta Commit Ib
Õpetaja: Seni kaua, kuni No nüüd peaks ee, nägema Juba komponenti ka. Vaata, näete komponent. Saad Track Ida
Õpetaja: Locations View. Ei, ole. Ta ei näita jälle. Vaata niimoodi. Ma mõtlesin niimoodi. Sa oled.
Õpetaja: Mis, Mis selle funktsionaalsus on? Ma ei saa aru, et rida read lihtsalt vä.
Õpetaja: Vaatame rida. Seitseteist. Kolm, seitse, Ee Kontroll G. Rida seitseteist,
Õpetaja: Noh, läheb selle Tv peale. Kus sees see on?
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlesin, et ta näitab ka nagu alamkompon.
Õpetaja: See vist ei tööta. Lihtsalt vaata, kuna Ta ei suuda üleüldiselt seda avada. Mul on muidugi mitu Tab I ka lahti. Aga teile tööta samamoodi? Niikuinii on ju.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, kui Meeting Lõpuks läheb Bushiga. Ka Kas keegi üritab järgi tulla? Mulle Praegu või mitte? Kes ma ootan? Buss läheks.
Õpetaja: Ei, so sorry. Bussi peal Ikka, nüüd
Õpetaja: annan teile hetke aega. Samal ajal
Õpetaja: võib siis arutada, et, ee, mida teha. Lihtsalt taaski mõttes,
Õpetaja: et me tahame nüüd seda klotsi teha veel eraldi klotside Eks
Õpetaja: Me tahame teha niimoodi, nagu siin taaskis, on kirjas, et ee. Meil tuleb eraldi location Name Input number of Input Transaction, Type checkbox,
Õpetaja: et me tahame veel teha. Alamkomponenti. Me teeme tegelikult ma päriselus. Seda ei teeks Ainukene, mis ma võibolla päriselt mõtleks, oleks see transaction types.
Õpetaja: Võibolla selle ma teeksin eraldi komponendiks, aga lihtsalt, teha nagu silt ja input Nagu sellest ma nagu eraldi komponenti kohe kindlalt ei teeks. Aga me teeme seda tehnilist keerukust, et meil tekiks lihtsalt see Grandchild asi.
Õpetaja: Me tahame seda emiitimist ja Props I ja Kõike seda nagu teha rohkem kui üks korrus.
Õpetaja: Sest et päris. Kujutage ette, et teil on mingi vaade,
Õpetaja: siis teil võibolla seal mingid vormid asjad. Ja tegelikult tulevadki mingid nupud ja asjad, mis on taaskasutatud ja mingid. Mida iganes, et teil niikuinii päriselus juhtub, ikkagi seda, et ee, Korruseid tuleb vähe rohkem kui ainult Barent ja Child
Õpetaja: Vähemalt niukses projektis, kus Ee üritatakse tõesti teha asju klotsidega ja taaskasutatav, Hästi, palju siis On Selge see, et kõik need asjad on juba eraldi klotsid.
Õpetaja: Nii, kas saite järgi Või keegi veel tuleb käsi püsti,
Õpetaja: Okei, ehk siis, Kui me tuleme nüüd siia Location View Sse, siis meil natukene on Juba Asjad läinud siin paremaks.
Õpetaja: Tõmbame veidi asju kokku. Ee, mis meil Ei ole vaja vaadata.
Õpetaja: Ee, Tõmbame niimoodi kokku, et keskendume praegult ainult lihtsalt sellele.
Õpetaja: Ee, põhimõtteliselt selle kuulumine saab ka. Seda Ei saa, sest Siin on mõlemad Location form.
Õpetaja: Selle kolumni saab ikkagi panna niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: meie tegime eraldi klotsi. Location form.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mis me tahame teha, on See, et me läheme, tükeldame seda edasi.
Õpetaja: Läheme siia sisse. Control Click.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Siin on siis input ja label
Õpetaja: form floating. See Siin on Meil Location name. See siin on number of. See on transaction types. Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Praegult tuleb Props kõik sisse. Location i järgi, on Nii
Õpetaja: kui me võtame selle esimese siit lahti. Kus on Ee, siis? Mis Objekti on siin kasutatud? Siin on kasutatud Location Id ja tegelikult läheb vaja ainult location Name i vastatajale.
Õpetaja: Kui me praegu teeme sellest eraldi komponendi, siis arvake ära, mis Propsi ta alla tahab Saata.
Õpetaja: Kas Location I või Location Name I.
Õpetaja: Saada Pika Location I. Aga Kuidas oleks meil mõistlik
Õpetaja: meil? Ei ole tervet objekti vaja mida. Sa teed seal selles input Is, kus sul on vaja ainult saada seda väärtust. Location Name. Ehk siis nüüd. Ta käitub nii, nagu ta käituma peab. Ta võtab ikka selle välimise objekti. Aga me ise hakkame asju kindlasti muutma.
Õpetaja: Meil ei ole mõtet anda tervet location objekti sinna alla kaasa, Sellepärast ärge unustage ära.
Õpetaja: Rops peab jälgima muutusi.
Õpetaja: Props peab jälgima muutusi. Vaata, onju? Aga meil ei ole vaja jälgida seal tervet seda objekti Seal, selles väikses inputkastikeses vaid Meil on ainult Location Name I vaja jälgida.
Õpetaja: Nii, no vaatame, mis saab.
Õpetaja: Võtad tuleme, võtame selle Tv, kinni
Õpetaja: Kui me niimoodi kokku tõmmata ka on ju? Kui tahame see esimene
Õpetaja: Noh Näed, ta on ilusti sinine Parem klõps,
Õpetaja: prefaktor, Aidake meeles hoida, ka, et praegu kõik tekivad siia Views kausta alla. Sest Kuna need hetkel see esimene Location View oli. Vaata, me peame pärast tõstma nad Kuhugi paika Ka enne seda ma korra otsustan. Ruta ära. Ee location name input. Noh, paneme siis selle Sama, mis on.
Õpetaja: Ee, kit, mitte Kit Ee. Refaktor Komponent Location Name input,
Õpetaja: Mis ta kaasa annab? Me näeme, ta annab kaasa
Õpetaja: Location objekti, onju? See on ainukene asi, mis Me tunneme, et meile ei meeldi
Õpetaja: script I osa. Tulge juba siit. Hiire või selle keyboardiga. Näete, siit tuled. Hoid shift i peal,
Õpetaja: Control Iks, tulete siia alla. Võite paar korda Panete. Selle skrip I alla.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siin kõik klapib. Vaata Value Location name ja nii edasi, onju? Tema ütleb, et sisse tuleb. Ee, asi on objekt.
Õpetaja: Siin on nüüd natuke ainult copy paste i teema.
Õpetaja: Tuleme Copy. Me selle location name I ja paneme selja hoopis Propsi
Õpetaja: ja ütleme, et see mis sisse tuleb, on string ja siit kustutame selle Location I ära,
Õpetaja: et jääb Niimoodi saate mõttest aru, on ju? Ei ole mõtet meil tervet objekti alla anda.
Õpetaja: Saad alati proovida.
Õpetaja: Ma valisid vale.
Õpetaja: Sa pead igaühe kontra minema tagasi paar sammu. Ta peaks suutma seda. Vaata, et ta kustutab ise ära. Selle loodud komponendi,
Õpetaja: võibolla mitte. Võibolla peletan ka Said,
Õpetaja: korter on see, et on üsna liberaalne, et saab minna tagasi päris palju samme vahel mingisugusest sammust ette. Mingi konkreetse asjaga. Tal võib tekkida pidur, Et ta ei ole võimeline enam nagu taastama mingit olukorda.
Õpetaja: Sa ei tekkinud sellel. Vist oli vaja kirjutada, sest et ennem oli siin Propsi asemel oli location ja Objekt oli onju kõige lihtsam objekti defineerimine. Nemal saaks ka niimoodi panna. Vaata, onju objekt,
Õpetaja: aga meil on nüüd muutus. Ütleme, et see on string.
Õpetaja: Siin ei ole vaike väärtust. Sellepärast, et see andmed Flowad ülevalt. Kui ma tahan panna mingi vaike väärtust, mäletate, Siis tuleb see asi laiendada. On ju? Teeme laienduse. Ütleme, et Taip on endiselt.
Õpetaja: Ee, String, Ärge seda tehke, string ja kui tahad, et Kui sa mingit väärtust ei tule.
Õpetaja: Bla, bla, bla, blabla. Sattume stardil.
Õpetaja: Aga mina siin. Seda vajadust ei ole. Kus me tegime niimoodi Noh, City Structor. Näiteks oli ju
Õpetaja: väike Väärtus Oli, et ee, kõik linnad,
Õpetaja: kui ei tule midagi muud. Sisse.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siin, siin korrusel, kõik on Ee, mis puudutab seda, et asju kuvada.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on see asi, et see asi on muutunud.
Õpetaja: Kui teha see asi siniseks ja vaitada Kontrolltühikut,
Õpetaja: siis tegelikult on hoopis Location Name see Props, mida me soovime.
Õpetaja: Ja me ei soovi Location objekti anda kaasa vaid osa sellest, mis Ma kirjutan siia punkt Ja
Õpetaja: nüüd, aa. Praegult on nüüd niimoodi, et ta ei oska meile. See on nüüd. Ta ei oska pakkuda seda, Et mis siia? Mis selles Location is objektis on? Miks sellepärast, et see Flow ülevalt sisse see mudel on meil siin Location Views.
Õpetaja: Ta ei suuda nii mitu astet nagu aru saada, et siin sees on Niuke väli nagu Location Name.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis selle peab lihtsalt ise kirjutama siia niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et ta ide ei aidanud. Praegult, Kui meil oleks mingi Web Storm, mis on mõeldud veebidisa veebide arendamiseks, siis võibolla seal see Võibolla toimiks, et ta saab aru, nagu sellest
Õpetaja: ei pakkunud.
Õpetaja: Ta võib pakkuda lihtsalt, kui sa piisavalt palju kirjutad, et ta vaatab ka üle projekti. Mingisuguseid väärtuseid. Aga mitte sellisel. Kujul ei pakkunud, et kui ma tulen, panen siia lihtsalt punkt.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi ei paku Jaa, no kui juba Niimoodi siis ta siis. Ta vaatab, seda et ta kuskil. Vaata, ta näeb seda kuskil mujal. Seda Location name. I Ta näeb mingi muus failis muuta, et Location name.
Õpetaja: Aga ta ei paku niimoodi, et kontroll tühik.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et siia päeva lõpuks siia võib sisse voolata, Mida iganes
Õpetaja: Sa võid ütleme niimoodi, et siia peaks tulema. Location Object on I. Noh, aga kui tegelikult, kus ma seda teen?
Õpetaja: Kui mina Location Formi Annan Location Isse kaasa. Hoopis lihtsalt stringi. Näiteks,
Õpetaja: ma olen saanud Aa, aga nii palju ei taha, et nad jäävad.
Õpetaja: Aa, noh, selles mõttes, Oota, see ongi see mõte. Need asjad ei ole omavahel seotud.
Õpetaja: See location form ei ole tegelikult seotud. Ühegi muu asjaga
Õpetaja: ei ole seotud Sinu enda hoolitseda on see, et, ee. Sina teed niimoodi, et sa defineerid ära. Mis? Asjad tulevad sisse? Sa programmeerid kõik asjad ära. Vaata, Sa pead nagu selles mõttes ise nagu kandma hoolt. Vaata, et õiged asjad lähevad ee, õigetesse kohtadesse alla ja õige sisuga ja nii edasi
Õpetaja: Me ei kasuta. Me ei kasuta Type Script I. Kui me kasutaks type script I, siis seal oleksid Objektid ja objektid on ära defineeritud. Seal Seal tal tegelt ideergi. Selle mudeli ta nagu saaks kätte.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga me ei kasuta seda lähenemist.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: meil läheb Location for meil läheb ilusti. Location. Aga nüüd location name input. I läheb lihtsalt ainult Location Name
Õpetaja: on küsimusi. Selles kohas
Õpetaja: mitte midagi ei muutunud. Ee, ongi See, et me lihtsalt teeme eraldi klotse kohe. Me saame juba vaadata. Oest ka neid klotse nagu sellisel kujul. Vähemalt et. Hei, vaatame juba, Vaatame seda, kas vastab tõele, et kui vaadata väga pikalt äpp on kõige parem,
Õpetaja: siis on vastavalt. Ruudile on Location View on niiöelda Child, Siis tuleb location form.
Õpetaja: Mm, Mingil põhjusel Location for. Me ei kuva, et tal on tegelikult Child.
Õpetaja: Huvitav, miks
Õpetaja: sul kuvab või see võib olla ka mingi refresh Is ju
Õpetaja: Aa Nüüd tuli on nii,
Õpetaja: Kui mõelda. See. Vaata, et, ee, Kui me mõtleme Location View St, siis Location Forum, on nii? On ju üks tõks eemal ja Location Name input on.
Õpetaja: Kes on need omavahel, onju? Grand Parent ja Grandchild.
Õpetaja: Nii, Nüüd läheme sinna Location Formi ja me teeme selle teise Ee, number of Input. Iga täpselt samamoodi. Võtame selle kogu selle sisu. Ütleme. Ole Hea
Õpetaja: refaktureeri Ja tee sellest uus komponent.
Õpetaja: Number of Atms input.
Õpetaja: Jällegi, ta tegi selle selliselt. No, sinna saab selle script I osa tõsta, alla. Teeme selle asja ära. Nii nagu ikka.
Õpetaja: Ad, ad, Lisa, Lisa Kit. I.
Õpetaja: Ta tegi täpi pealt selle sama asja. Vaata, et tema Tema võtab propsina Annab. Kogu objekti kaasa. Ja, noh, mis siin sees kasutatakse? Seda kasutatakse. Me tahame teha siin täpipealt sama protsessi ära, et Me tahame öelda, et ei ei
Õpetaja: Jõena voolab sisse. Mitte Location objekt, vaid hoopis number of Htms.
Õpetaja: Mis on vaikimisi? No mis ta on number.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta on hintaga, aga. Aga siin, ee, siin. Java Scriptis ei ole. Nagu kõik Numbrid on numbrid
Õpetaja: ka koma. Number on number
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui me muutsime selle muutuja nime ära, Noh, siis nüüd me ei saa. Vii see ju ei renderduks enam. Millest sa jahud? Vaata, Siin pole mingit Location It. Ei, tata Bloki Props Pole Mingit Location It, aga ei olegi nii mõeldud, vaid tuleb
Õpetaja: Ja jälle samamoodi, et Nüüd see koht, kus me seda välja kutsume.
Õpetaja: See koht, kus me seda välja kutsume, nüüd hakkab punkt jama ajama, et ma klikin siia, No ei ole enam, Sest et nüüd on siin hoopis
Õpetaja: Number of Adams on. Ja me ei taha anda sinna Location objekti vaid ühte Osa sellest Location objektist
Õpetaja: klapib.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, kuidas üldse kood nagu läheb, Top. Levelil läheb järjest väiksemaks. Ennem oli siin ka mingid mudru. Kõik see Kood, mis on siin? Kõik see kood, mis on siin, kõik oleks selles form Input, is onju. Aga Mis me nüüd nagu sellest võitsime, on see, et
Õpetaja: siin on palju vähem mudru.
Õpetaja: No nüüd on see järgmine asi. Ju.
Õpetaja: See Transaction Type kuvamine samamoodi. See Kõik on ühe Divi sees.
Õpetaja: See võiks olla eraldi transaction Types Checkbox.
Õpetaja: See võikski olla Transaction type check boxes. Aga Mulle lihtsalt ei meeldi kuidagi niuke sõna Pokses
Õpetaja: transaction type. Nagu Neid on mitu. Ma nagu pigem paneks siis transaction types. Paned seal selle mitmuse ära. Checkbox on siis see nagu Nagu Input. I niiöelda
Õpetaja: representeerib
Õpetaja: valgeks, et ee. On talle sama perioodil.
Õpetaja: No sealt, kas siin on?
Õpetaja: Aga alguses sealt vist ei ole, niukest asja
Õpetaja: Ta ütles sulle täpselt seda, mis probleem tal oli.
Õpetaja: Sa viitad muutujale, mida mina, nagu ei leia.
Õpetaja: Kas keegi vajab ka mitte või võib edasi teha praegult
Õpetaja: käsi püsti või keegi soovib ka mitte.
Õpetaja: Okei, lähme edasi. Võite vaadata ka lihtsalt natukene. No nüüd on see viimane Ee checkboxid, et kogu see Dv. I. Võtame siit jälle samamoodi.
Õpetaja: No siis saab võtta refaktor. Aa, seda pakub parem klõps.
Õpetaja: Refactor Ekstract View Komponent.
Õpetaja: Kurat, mis see nüüd oli? Siis?
Õpetaja: Ee, transaction types checkbox.
Õpetaja: Noh, ja tagasi
Õpetaja: Trend Action.
Õpetaja: Types tšekk.
Õpetaja: Kas oli üks sõna? Kaks sõna, Ikka üks sõna. Muidugi, Boks Enter.
Õpetaja: Noh, ad, ad. Loomulikult on osa projektist Script I. Koristame siit ära, Paneme siia alla poole, nii nagu meile meeldib, ütleme siis. Meile meeldib see disainerview.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on küsimus. Vaata, et mida siin, nagu tegelikult kasutatakse veel, onju? Tegelikult kasutatakse küljest ainult Seda Transaction types I on, nii
Õpetaja: et me tahaksime samamoodi teha, et Propsina ei tule location sisse, vaid tuleb. Propsina sisse.
Õpetaja: Transaction types.
Õpetaja: Noh, ära. Ei, on ka iseenesest objekt. Aga see on nagu, väga, täpselt objekt. Me tahame ikka öelda, et Tuleb,
Õpetaja: tuleb sisse ja Vaadake, nüüd, Me kustutame ära selle Location i siit täiesti kõik endiselt. Nagu ka nagu kattub
Õpetaja: kuskile, ei ole viidatud Location ile. Noh, Sanity check control F
Õpetaja: Location ei leia siit failist midagi. Olgu,
Õpetaja: kui nüüd minna vaatama Location formi, siis ee. Nüüd kujutage ette uuesti. Vaata onju. No mis, Kujutage ette, me võime siit teha. Ee, ma panen Local History,
Õpetaja: et me meie koodivõrdlus on niimoodi, et meie hetkelahendus keskenduge just selle template Osale. Oi, kurat, suureks. Ee, et praegult paremal pool on meie. See kood, Niuke ta välja Näeb
Õpetaja: niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Kui ta. Kui me alustasime, siis Ta nägi välja siukene.
Õpetaja: Oota natukene, Võibolla. Vot nii,
Õpetaja: et kumb kood teile, tundub, Mida tahaks lugeda, kui tulete seda komponenti Location formi vaatama Parempoolne
Õpetaja: parempoolset. Vist on natukene lihtsam lugeda, et saada aru, et mis toimub. Eriti kui sa nagu paaritad seda selle mõttega, on ju, et, Ee, mis sa siin Nagu näed, onju. Ta on siin ka, Refresh.
Õpetaja: Siis mul võibolla meeldib korra seda inspekti isegi rohkem kasutada. Mine Ära siit.
Õpetaja: Aa, siit meeldiks seda. Voed lihtsalt rohkem lahti teha ja teeme natukene suuremaks.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kui ma tulen, hakkan Ru kogu vaade
Õpetaja: location Vaade on Kogu see asi on nii.
Õpetaja: City Strop Town On see osa
Õpetaja: location Forum On kogu see osa
Õpetaja: location Name Input On see Osa Number of On see osa Checkbox?
Õpetaja: Ahah, Mingil põhjusel midagi ei näita ka. Nagu midagi on nagu mingi jama või
Õpetaja: kuskil on mingi Lõk on sees. Aa, Sest et me ei ole teinud korda veel. Seda, Kuidas ee, barentist asju kaasa antakse? Mingeid andmeid ei ole. Vaata, Pugi on, on ju?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ma panen selle kinni selle. Vaata, et lähme vaatame, mis on valesti.
Õpetaja: Transaction types. Kas seal on üldse niukest
Õpetaja: muutujat nagu Location ei ole, sest me muutusime ära, et Transaction types ära ei
Õpetaja: ehk. Siis meil on seal Niukene muutuja, mida sisu Ei anta
Õpetaja: Anname sisse, aga me anname jälle. Vaata, kui annad kogu objekti, siis tuleb mingi jama sellest.
Õpetaja: Me peame ütlema, et ei, ei, Ta on ainult kaasa
Õpetaja: Transaction types sinna alla kaasa. Noh, nüüd peaks joonistama.
Õpetaja: Kas on seda koodi parem lugeda
Õpetaja: kui kõike Vaata, siin on See mõte on. See. Vaata, et me nagu kapseldame. Ära vaata erinevad koodilõigud kuskile erinevatesse kohtadesse ja need klotsidena. Selles mõttes töötavad, seal on Mitmekordne võit meil on. Potentsiaali taaskasutuseks
Õpetaja: saaks uuesti kasutada. Noh, mida suurem on projekt, seda suurem taaskasutus. Tõenäosus on
Õpetaja: eriti kui mingi rippmenüüd ja Mingid asjad, nagu
Õpetaja: et sa saad neid uuesti kasutada. On ju mingid vormid ka jälle. Ee, mitmes kohas. Täiesti tõenäoline. Ja isegi isegi kui Ainult ühe korra. Kasutad
Õpetaja: siis koodi. Loetavus. Improve,
Õpetaja: muidugi. Iga korraga tuleb juurde keerukus. Selles mõttes vaata et et sa pead nagu ise abstraktselt hakkama mõtlema. Neid asju enam ei ole. Kõik siin otse Html is kirjas. Vaid kui sa tahad nagu mingit üldpilti endale kätte saada, nagu pead. Ahah, Arvestan sellega kõigega, mis ma siin näen. Ja tuled siia ja vaatad Arvestan kõigega, mis ma siin näen. Siin Tradeoff on ka olemas.
Õpetaja: Nagu midagi. Võidad midagi, kaotad.
Õpetaja: Aga, noh, ma ei tea, minu jaoks. Ütleme minu jaoks. Alati on koodi. Loetavus on absoluutselt kõige tähtsam asi.
Õpetaja: Ee, jaa, muidugi.
Õpetaja: Aa, Sest et kõik need praegu alguse sai see, et me ekstraktisime selle Location Formi Kuna ta oli selles kaustas See Location View. Siis ta tuli siia kõrvale.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis me peame tekitama tõesti komponentsi alla. Nüüd komponentsi alla. Oleks natuke mõistlik kui, hakkab siia väga palju faile tulema. Siis see ei ole hea. Iga kord on. See on nagu normaalne protsess.
Õpetaja: Sa ei pea ennem hakkama tegema Mingisuguseid katalooge ja süsteemi, enne kui nagu reaalselt tekib vajadus selleks, mis ei tähenda muidugi, et sa ei või kohe seda teha, aga mis Te arvate, missuguse
Õpetaja: Ee, mina paneks siia komponentsi jälle Palju lihtsamalt. Valdkond.
Õpetaja: Valdkond on ühel või teisel viisil.
Õpetaja: Location.
Õpetaja: Kas Location Stabel võiks minna? Sinna alla, et kuidas ma kiirelt leian? Ülesse. Vaata, Locations asjad.
Õpetaja: Muidugi, sest et seda tabelit saaks. Locations tabelit saaks ju kasutada uuesti kuskil kui tahaks.
Õpetaja: Hetkel on ta Kasutatud. Atm S Views, onju? Aga selle ma tõstaks sinna alla. Location on seal.
Õpetaja: Mingid asjad on ka Vaata, Mis on Share Itud? Siis ma teeksingi ka. Osta Common See Location Forum võiks minna sinna alla
Õpetaja: Location Name Input võiks minna location i Alla
Õpetaja: Number of number of Htms input.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta on praegu sellega seotud. Vot lõpuks paneks sinna location I alla. Hetkel isegi mõtleb. Võibolla Oleks võinud olla ta nimi Location Number of liiga pikaks ei tahaks, Mida vähem, seda parem ikkagi.
Õpetaja: Aga ma paneks ta sinna alla ja Siin on ka nüüd niimoodi, et ega siin ei ole mingit absoluutset tõde. Vaata, kuidas peaks tegema
Õpetaja: vaid meeskond ise. Nagu otsustab või keegi Arhitekt siis, kui see on kuidagi selliselt paika pandud.
Õpetaja: Kas teeme täna jälle kaksteist viieteistkümneni ja siis teeme. Sobib,
Õpetaja: et, ee, et siin on nagu. See et kuidas tundub loogiline. Ja vot. Vot see on see asi, millega tavaliselt isegi keegi väga ei nõusta. Ma ütlen ka seinoritel, alati Tegi mingit uut asja. Ma küsisin
Õpetaja: konkreetses projektis. Konkreetse fjatuuri ehitamisel on mingi kaasatud ka mingi seenior. Olete küsinud, kus ma võiks panna Ja pane lihtsalt niisama kuhugi praegu. Ee, noh,
Õpetaja: lõppkokkuvõttes. Kuidagi lõpuks hakkab kuidagi paika loksutama. Ja kui keegi arvab, et oleks asju ümber tõsta, Niikuinii ajas see muutub. Täna on mingi niukene paigutus. See asi hakkab kasvama, kasvama, kasvama ja üks hetk hakatakse jälle nagu grupeerime mingeid asju Omavahel, et siin nagu lappes läheb,
Õpetaja: kui kui ühte kausta tekib juba väga palju faile. See on nagu Trigger. Vaata, et Oot. Oot, oot,
Õpetaja: et et võibolla peaks kuidagi grupeerima. See ei tähenda, et tingimata nii on.
Õpetaja: Aa, aga võibolla peaks grupeerima. No see, ma ei tõsta, onju?
Õpetaja: Siin peaks olema ainult Vi Vi, onju? See asi Veel viimane asi, mis tuleks tõsta
Õpetaja: sinna location i alla hetkel ja nad on tihedalt Location iga seotud.
Õpetaja: Ja kui nüüd mingi hetk juhtub seda, et sa hakkad kuskil teistes kohtades seda kasutama, siis väga tavaline asi on ka, See, et tehakse mingi niukene kaust,
Õpetaja: Seda ei ole vaja praegu teha, Aga või Share Com on jagatud.
Õpetaja: Kui sa kuidagi vaatad, et kurat Siin kasutan. Seal kasutan.
Õpetaja: Noh, kumma juurde panen? Siis tehakse ka niukest asja, et paneme need mujale.
Õpetaja: Või kui otsustame, et kuidagi nimi ikkagi õigustab, et ta on kuskil kaustas, et ta kuidagi rohkem kuulub. Ühte Siis jätad sinna. Mis, Sest et seda mujal ka kasutatakse, vaata, Nii, et see ei pea olema päris nii ka,
Õpetaja: et need lähenemised on erinevad.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: ta ta selles mõttes teeb igal pool need muudatused. Vaata, et kui me läheme nüüd, vaatame näiteks. Ja kui te vaatate neid importe
Õpetaja: komponent Slocation, et need koodiread tegelikult muutusid, aga see ongi see, et ta, ta teeb seda niimoodi ise. Vaata meie eest. Et Kus on viited nendele failidele? Neid ta hoiab.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin on jälle. Vaata, Yes, vaata, et meil on nagu Niukene asi. Nagu idea. Vaata, mis nagu lubab teha niukseid, lihtsaid toimingud ja me ei pea muretsema, et Nüüd hakkab käsitsi otsima. Kui vanasti oli. Kogu asi, oli nagu Põhimõtteliselt niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Noh, et kirjuta lihtsalt tekste ja koodi vaadata, siis sa peaksid minema ja hakkama jälle ebima. Vaata, et sa viitad ju muutusid.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: nüüd oleks vaja korra proovida, ka et kas see asi nagu. Töötab, Onju,
Õpetaja: et, ee, need asjad tulevad. Mis tuuakse andmetega ära Korra võiks proovida kõiki väärtusi, et paneb mingid väärtused, et kas nad, alla? No Automaatide arvi juba näeme. Üks tuleb, onju? Ärme unusta ära, et vaata, et meie selles vihlus ma nüüd panen nagu Close,
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt, ah, mitte seda ei tahtnud kinni panna, Aga okei, et, ee. Kõik need andmed hetkel, mis on siin selles Location objektis peavad alla Flowma korra võin läbi mängida ja panen siia üks.
Õpetaja: Panen siia. Aa, siia. Panen, Pbb, Las see pilt läheb. Kasvab katki. Vahet. Pole,
Õpetaja: Noh, need nad need tulevad internetist niikuinii. Ma näen, et neid kuvatakse.
Õpetaja: Kui ma ütlen Refresh, siis ma tahan näha, et on valitud Mingi linn on Aa automaatide arv Ja tuleb need. Ja pilt, mis läheb katki. Fine.
Õpetaja: Nagu et nagu Proof of. Ma näen, et need andmed vähemalt ühtepidi on praegu Süngis,
Õpetaja: Mis mina? Mis on siin objektis selles Location objektis Flow alla, on nii? See on täpselt selline setup mida me tahame teha.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Me tahame hakata nüüd tegelema selle osaga. Aga kui tulevad mingisugused muutused?
Õpetaja: Vaata, Transaction. Selle kauba on see, kui tuleb alt sündmus.
Õpetaja: Vabandust, see läheb alla praegult. Vale asi.
Õpetaja: Vot seda ei olegi. Ära progetad. City, Strop Town Is Käivitub niukene Tegevus change I Peale
Õpetaja: kus, electris Toimub muudatus. Event New City Selected on nii saadetakse ülesse pakikene.
Õpetaja: Sellest väljust, mis on valitud, tehakse veel numbriks. See on vana kood, on ju
Õpetaja: Meil on praegult, et mitte midagi ei toimu
Õpetaja: või nüüd. See on nüüd kaasategemise koht. Aga me tahame, et ükshaaval hakata lahendama nüüd seda ära, et
Õpetaja: alla info, aga hakkab ülesse ka tulema tagasi, kui muudatused toimuvad Sellepärast, et minu see City Id on praegult siin vaikimisi, noh Ma tulen, panen tagasi. Ta ühe peale nii nagu ta oli.
Õpetaja: Vabandust, mitte ühe peale, vaid nulli peale. Kõik linnad või vali linn on ju antud kontekstis,
Õpetaja: Kui mina tahan valida pärnu.
Õpetaja: Ja Kui ma. Nüüd võtan selle komponendi lahti ja vaatan, nagu, et. Hei, mis on Mul Selles
Õpetaja: praegult City Id ei peaks olema null ta alla Flow ülesse ei tule. Aga see Child komponent ju saadab sõnumit. Event i
Õpetaja: Ahah. Üks asi, mis meil ei ole tehtud tegelikult, aga me peaksime ära. Tegema. Lähme korra sinna korra. Muudame seda koodi paremaks.
Õpetaja: Meil on siin Name, meil on siin. Props.
Õpetaja: Vahel on Methods ka, Aga meil on veel üks blokk, mida me pole kasutanud. Aga peaks kasutama ja mits
Õpetaja: Mis tähendab,
Õpetaja: ee süntaxiga? Jään nüüd hätta. Mina ei mäleta, mismoodi on Siin saab ära deklareerida.
Õpetaja: Eelkõige Brauser. See Tegelikult ei Mitt läheb niikuinii Siit see vend. Aga me tegelikult tahaks ka öelda Voe tööriistadele asjadele, et siit võivad minna ja mitid teele. Täpsemalt selline mitt,
Õpetaja: Sellise nimega Aga ma ei oska seda. Ma ei oska seda kirjutada. Siis ma ütlen Kontrollerit ka.
Õpetaja: Ütlen, et ee, kuidas ee. Siin emit süntaksis käib,
Õpetaja: Ma isegi on nii laisk, et ma ei viitsi hüüd panna siin. Vaatame, kas saab aru, mida aru saab
Õpetaja: ja mits käib niimoodi ee nimi.
Õpetaja: Sinu komponendis emiteeritakse Event City Selected koos number väärtusega. Seega objekti sündaks Ee valideerimisel oleks selline.
Õpetaja: Ee
Õpetaja: ja. No Davai. Proovime siis seda õppida peast ära kirjutama, et ei peaks Iga kord, et kõigepealt läheb siia nimi, Neid võib mitmeid olla. See on siis võti, Üks koma on puudu
Õpetaja: nüüd väärtus.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan, kas see kontroll tühikuga pakub. Mingisugust süntoksit ei ole. Siis peab ise teadma,
Õpetaja: et tuleb panna niimoodi sulud Mingi väärtus City It
Õpetaja: funktsioon. Edaspidi me kindlalt kopime selle mingi põrgu nagu, niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ja et see return Ib numbreid, Noh, is Integare City Id
Õpetaja: korra. Nüüd vaatame korra. Kus seda City Id D üldse mainitakse? Mitte kusagil ju.
Õpetaja: Ma otsin korra, et miks just selline nimi, nagu Aa, ikkagi on ikkagi.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, see on lihtsalt muutuja.
Õpetaja: Mis see vahe on? Kohe vaatame, kui ma tulen, teen Refresh I, te Tahate korra seda? Me lähme kohe pausile. Niikuinii Saate pärast järgi tulla. See Ei, ole nii tähtis. See on nii keeruline. Syntaks nagu, et Mina nagu ei oskaks. Miks ma ütlesin, et ma ei oska seda? Ma ei tea, ilmselt saab kuidagi lihtsamalt. Kui seda kui paketti kaasa ei lähe,
Õpetaja: siis läheb umbes kuidagi niimoodi. Ma arvan, ongi kõik midagi taolist. Ee, ta läheb Eventi ülesse. Nüüd see vahe on selles, et Vaadake Ka see tööriist.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tulen. Location View ja ma lähen.
Õpetaja: Lähen Ee City Strop Down I peale
Õpetaja: Korra teile, Fresh I Ma Pakun, et ta peaks tegelikult ütlema. Vaata, et siit sündmused lähevad.
Õpetaja: Võibolla ei ütle ka. Ma ei mäleta. Aa, ma kohe küsin ka, miks See on vajalik City Strop Town
Õpetaja: Ei. See, on okei et, ta ongi null jah.
Õpetaja: Ta, ju sisse voolab null.
Õpetaja: See. On props Vaata. See on õige, sa mõtled seda?
Õpetaja: Ma Pigem tahtsin siin näha, et uut blokki nimega Ei, Mits.
Õpetaja: Äkki ma vaatan äkki parentist, siis kuidagi on seda, teada, Sest et siin on Event Lisenar.
Õpetaja: Ma. Ma korra nüüd küsin. Vaata, et miks nad on seda üldse vaja.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga Miks on seda üldse vaja?
Õpetaja: Ma kirjutan ka Kaldkriips. Skills.
Õpetaja: Skill Aa Loo uus õppematerjal, et äkki ta teeks kohe. Ma ei tea, kas Ta saab aru või mitte,
Õpetaja: et tee õppematerjal ka. Mind juba huvitab see natuke detailsemalt. Nagu
Õpetaja: No muidu poleks juba kommiki ära, Nagu, Ee,
Õpetaja: Aga Lähme tegeleme korra praegu. Siis selle teise poolega. Nii või naa, et Copy käes. Ee, nimi.
Õpetaja: Me teame, et alt tuleb Ee City Id.
Õpetaja: Kui midagi valid, see tuleb parentisse ja tuleb välja. Lähme siis sinna. Location View Sse
Õpetaja: siin. Kus on see dropdown Näed? Siin on Sisend,
Õpetaja: sisend, sisend, sisend. See kõik läheb alla. Nüüd paneme et ät. Kui tuleb Event,
Õpetaja: ma küsin teile, et alt tuleb Event ja Pakiga antakse Ee City Id Selected City Id, Mis me tahame teha. Sellega
Õpetaja: Me saame selle sama real selle ära. Teha.
Õpetaja: Mis me tahame teha Sellega Ei, me oleme parentes juba. Vaata, mida me enam emiteerime
Õpetaja: Mis me siin tahame teha? Selle alt tuleb väärtus, et sa valisid mi? Näed, alla läheb
Õpetaja: alla. Läheb Väärtus location i küljest. City Id väärtus.
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd alt tuleb uus väärtus ülesse, paneme muud asja, mis muuta
Õpetaja: Dishon.
Õpetaja: Noh, see sama asi. Vaata, mis konks on see, et meie hoiame sünkroonis seda väärtust on Nii
Õpetaja: Alla läheb. See on ju? Näed, Alla läheb Selected City Id Location Punkt City Id. No nüüd me tahame öelda, et aga ülesse tuleb samamoodi selline sõnum. Siis me tahame öelda. Location Punkt
Õpetaja: City Id. Mis ma nüüd tagasi kirjutan,
Õpetaja: ei taha täita.
Õpetaja: Tahan öelda, et ma praegu puudutan Seda Hetkel ma näpuga, lihtsalt Puudutan seda,
Õpetaja: mis ma tahan. Puudud peale puudu, mis? Ma tahan, et juhtuks alt, tuleb mulle sõnum
Õpetaja: koos City Id Ga uue väärtusega, mis Ma tahan teha praegu. Ma niisama puudutan. Kui ma tahaks lugeda andmeid, siis ma praegu lihtsalt puudutan seda, mida ma tahan teha, et
Õpetaja: täpselt, et ma annan uue sisu. Talle vaata võrdub.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd alt tuleb meil pakina pakk ja selle paki saab kätte.
Õpetaja: Ee, event. Aga see dollariga, Vend, Niimoodi see.
Õpetaja: Vot see. See ütleb, et kui alt tuleb Event, siis palun. Location City It le Anna uus väärtus, mis tuleb Event iga.
Õpetaja: Vot nii.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me saame vaadata, kui ma teen. Refresh, ma panen selle asja kinni.
Õpetaja: Ma tegin tegelt lahti uuesti. Vaata, vaatan Location View D. Vaatan siit seest Location objektist. City Id väärtus on null, sest et lehte laadides Flow I küljest City Id välja, alla. Ma võin seda siin ka muuta. Korra näed? Ma muudan seda siin hoopis. Panen, et allavoolaks kaks on tallinn
Õpetaja: voolab alla, aga nüüd vaadake, Kui ma valin siit näiteks Tartu, siis ta muutub siin. Taustal, on nii?
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda. Me oleme saavutanud selle, ära, et alt emiititakse meile väärtus
Õpetaja: meil tema läheb otse Location I külge. Kuidas
Õpetaja: alt tuleb? Event New City Selected, Mis me tahame, teha? Et Location City Id saab uue väärtuse ja saab selle pakikese, mis event iga kaasa antakse.
Õpetaja: Nii, vaatame vahepeal. Ee, kas ta on midagi meile teinud Ka siis selle õppematerjali Tallinna.
Õpetaja: Nii, kas ta tegi valmis? Unversion Files defineerimine, Et vaatame ära? Siis mis ta räägib, et see oli Niukene väärt koht minu meelest õppida, et
Õpetaja: miks, kuidas. Mis moodi? Päris faili võite minu ekraanilt vaadata? Pärast Saate enda ekraanilt vaadata. Voe, mits defineerimine komponendis. Mis See on kui Child komponent saadab sündmuse pärandi limit, saab Voele ette öelda, millised sündmused see komponent välja saadab.
Õpetaja: Seda tehakse mitm võtmesõnaga ee Script blokis. Miks on seda üldse vaja? See on vabatahtlik, aga väga kasulik. Kolmel põhjusel dokumentatsioon mida see komponent teeb võõra komponentfailina, et kohe ära. Mis sündmusi see välja saadab,
Õpetaja: ei pea kogu templetit läbi lugema.
Õpetaja: Mõelge ka, Kui Scripto oleks üleval pool ja alles siis tuleb templeid, Siis saad kohe nagu pildida, et siin on mingid sündmused. Ehk siis tema. Peamine asi on nagu. See, et kui me vaatame lihtsalt seda Script I ainult.
Õpetaja: Ja me vaatame kohe. Seda on vale komponent.
Õpetaja: Lähme sinna. Child I, Meil on vaja minna, onju?
Õpetaja: Ma panen siit kõik Ee, ma panen Folding. Ee, kus on? Ma ei näe, Polnud
Õpetaja: Aa siinsamas. Ma panen ee, kõigepealt. Nii et ma teen scripti lahti, kui Ma vaataks kohe mitsi. Mul on kohe pilt, selge. Ma ei pea templetit hakkama vaatama, et. Oot, oot, oot, Kus siin. Sees on, See Mitt, Vaata, Ahah, onju, saate aru? Nüüd võib olla palju.
Õpetaja: See on tema nagu argument. Vaata, et ühest kohast näed, ära et siin on Niukene Event ja läheb mingisugune Number
Õpetaja: City Id.
Õpetaja: See siin on tinglik. See ei ole millegiga seotud. See on lihtsalt nagu mõtteliselt. Mis asi See. On see on City Id. Okei, Fair, Enough. Vaatame edasi, mis ta räägib
Õpetaja: koheselt, selge? See komponent emiteerib ühe sündmuse.
Õpetaja: Kaitsev W on Atribuuti läbikukkumise eest. Vahes on reegel, Kui Child Komponent saab. Ee, kuulajad Kliki. Aa ise ei deklareeri Ma mm
Õpetaja: Kui deklareeri pärand. Kasutab komponenti, et News ütleme. Seda.
Õpetaja: Minu jaoks on see segane. Ma ei saa sellest aru.
Õpetaja: Kaks Ee, Syntax lihtne invalideerimiseta. Loe Sündmuste nimedest ei kontrollitakse, Mis andmeid saadetakse hea kiireks kasutamiseks. Objekti sünta valideerimisega.
Õpetaja: Ohohoo, aitäh sulle Ei, taha. Seda keerulist süntaksit Tahtsingi seda
Õpetaja: me tegelikult ei huvita väga See osa, mis ta tahab pakkuda. See valideerimine ja kõik see.
Õpetaja: Teeme selle vitsi uuesti.
Õpetaja: Võtame selle loogilisest surust loogilise suluni. Ära.
Õpetaja: Paneme hoopis Siia kandilised sulud siia tulevad stringidena. Lihtsalt komadega eraldatud emitid, mis teele lähevad.
Õpetaja: See see, mis ta ütles, et siin mingi valideerib ka mingit Objekti ja sisu tegelt ei huvita.
Õpetaja: Kogemata võtsin. Nad võtsid asjast ära. Nüüd, ee. Niimoodi peaks olema vist
Õpetaja: Ja saate aru, et kui ma tahaks siia juurde panna. Siis tuleb ka oma ja tuleb järgmine mitt Saate mõttest aru Massiiv
Õpetaja: kasutame me seda lihtsalt süntaegset
Õpetaja: kõik rohkem ma Ei, soovi. See Nüüd ei defineeri seda Pakki ära. Põhimõtteliselt saate aru, et see on see ainukene asi, mis ta tegi Ekstra enam
Õpetaja: aga I would say like This is fine.
Õpetaja: Ja mingid muud põhjendused, mis ta räägib, on minu jaoks praegult nagu tuumafüüsika, Nagu et mis ta seal õppemateres. Kui tahaks süvitsi õppida, siis ma peaksin ütlema, et. Kuule,
Õpetaja: räägi nüüd normaalselt, nagu ja hakka nüüd sellest rääkima mulle midagi ja nii edasi, Aga see on natuke nagu Selleks aega pole. Nii, Lunch, aitab. Me oleme juba üle aja läinud.
Õpetaja: Kontroll ka. Proovime siis kuskil täistunni ajal tagasi tulla. Mina panen Committend Bush
Õpetaja: kogu staff. Iga mis siin on. Ee, kes tahab, tuleb siis enne uut sessiooni järgi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Head tunnet kõigile.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: ee,
Õpetaja: vist oli. Kalli ja. Ja alternatiiv on see, et istub sinu peal ja siis sa ei saa enam,
Õpetaja: saad endale Tartu.
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, et võiks vaadata.
Õpetaja: Ikka.
Õpetaja: Vau, jah,
Õpetaja: jah, väga hea küll.
Õpetaja: Ei, mhm, aitäh.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: Ahah,
Õpetaja: aitäh
Õpetaja: praegu.
Õpetaja: Palun
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: no Selles suhtes, palun.
Õpetaja: Ta ei ole telki.
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: ohh,
Õpetaja: mm,
Õpetaja: mhmh.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis. On.
Õpetaja: Mm
Õpetaja: Ee, Maitsesin just oreli.
Õpetaja: Mhmh, Oh, jah,
Õpetaja: kõige parem Pool tonni.
Õpetaja: Mhmh, Ee, vasaku juurde.
Õpetaja: Jah, on kahte laulu korraga. Tavaliselt Ei, tea.
Õpetaja: Jah, vabandust,
Õpetaja: toob kohtutup.
Õpetaja: Miks mul mingi loit laua peal Lõpuks siis räägi läbi.
Õpetaja: Aga Noh, see on teine tuli.
Õpetaja: Ma tahaks olla
Õpetaja: see. On. Mul siis sada kaotanud.
Õpetaja: Kohe teed Tuhat Ee, Päris puhul
Õpetaja: sai teisel kohale kaks õhtul peab mõtlema väga ilusasti.
Õpetaja: Uuesti tööle nõu Ei,
Õpetaja: eriti, kui meil on see kusagil teise koti peale.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleb mingi eestlane ja
Õpetaja: Satisfaction, kus? Noh, kuussada. Kakskümmend inimest. Ma sain viieteistkümnenda koha
Õpetaja: ja siis ma vaatasin, et ee, kaheteistkümnes koht oli teine eestlane. Ja ma sain ju koha Ja Nice
Õpetaja: pekki, Vend lõunas.
Õpetaja: Sa oled nagu,
Õpetaja: Vaat oli see tuhat aega.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: sobib sõjas olema. Praegu Mitte Siin bokserit. Kaugel
Õpetaja: umbus. Neli.
Õpetaja: Palun
Õpetaja: variera.
Õpetaja: Ta on nagu,
Õpetaja: Oi. Laps saab.
Õpetaja: Jah, Ee, Mm Palun välja.
Õpetaja: Mis vist oleks nii?
Õpetaja: No, Kaks, Kaks korraks on vist.
Õpetaja: Kuule, Mhm,
Õpetaja: jah,
Õpetaja: mhm.
Õpetaja: See on asju. Kui sellega ma siin mängib. Mingi sett.
Õpetaja: Väga hästi.
Õpetaja: Oo, loota õige
Õpetaja: Peale aspekti ei tule
Õpetaja: viie dollari.
Õpetaja: Elu Plast on liiga suur nagu
Õpetaja: olema. Siis ühe ristiga Satsa puhul
Õpetaja: pole mõtet.
Õpetaja: Mm suurepärane tuleb risti, Kui
Õpetaja: kakskümmend, kolm korda.
Õpetaja: No jah,
Õpetaja: oii.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ta räägib, Kuidas ta töötab seal. Enam
Õpetaja: Õiged küsimused, et mul on see kolme värviga vä leida betooni
Õpetaja: Ja ja on. Ikka sedasi, et kui on palju mängijaid.
Õpetaja: Ma ei usu, et, Oo, esimene küsimus ongi, kui palju, kes oleks, Kuni nii öeldakse, et kolm on miinum.
Õpetaja: Ja muidugi, mida rohkem seda pilli võtavad, ei ole siin. Me võibolla ei saa niimoodi, et see
Õpetaja: Kus kandis saadi? Seal on, Ee, toimib.
Õpetaja: Mhmh,
Õpetaja: oota.
Õpetaja: No
Õpetaja: kuule küsimust.
Õpetaja: Loed viis port asja kaasa.
Õpetaja: Kõige tähtsam ongi See räägi mõlemal on Eestlane.
Õpetaja: Jah, see on kauas.
Õpetaja: Jah, okei, jah.
Õpetaja: Te olete kahes nagu ühes mängus, onju?
Õpetaja: Ma ütlesin, kui sa näiteks oled pokkeris, siis saab Kuidagi nagu. Ja sellepärast ei saagi.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: milleks? Palun väga, väga
Õpetaja: bakteri oleks valmis.
Õpetaja: See ei ole suur, ma arvan. See on veits. Suurem Ikka, see annaks küll üheksa
Õpetaja: tahe, et seal ta on. Väga hea, et seal ei saa hoopis oma korteris
Õpetaja: korteri mingitelefoni puhul
Õpetaja: lähen ühe Korteriga tuled kahega tagasi
Õpetaja: ja seal on
Õpetaja: ise. Ma ei oskagi nagu
Õpetaja: ideaalne vastane. Kunagi oli töö. Ee, panid mängu. Paika mind õpetati ja Esimese mängima võiksin.
Õpetaja: Ma isegi ei saanud aru, kus ma võitsin.
Õpetaja: Aha, et
Õpetaja: ma oleksin näinud.
Õpetaja: Okei, tõsiselt, üks.
Õpetaja: Ta tegi täiesti koormata, et liiva poole taset
Õpetaja: nii lollid, et ei saa. Neid ei mõtlegi
Õpetaja: ja loodavad käima. Seda ma alatama kohta vist
Õpetaja: Kuidas mind järjest kukub, kukub, Kui sa rääkida tundsid minu vastu.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: mhm.
Õpetaja: Okei.
Õpetaja: Koolitelge On üks kohal, mis kool läheb
Õpetaja: taga ja vaatame, mis on öeldud.
Õpetaja: Mul on Mingi neli reklaami.
Õpetaja: Kas mäng oli siis parem? Mängus on Nelja on
Õpetaja: kolm.
Õpetaja: Mhm ei ole ülejäänud midagi
Õpetaja: Ee, Mitte voodi. Kodus moodi.
Õpetaja: Kaheksanda Korruse kaktus.
Õpetaja: Ma pean õpetama pizza söömise ma nagu viimane lõigu tükk veel käes. Üritan Ampsuta ampsata kätte. Kajakas. Vanasti Palun
Õpetaja: No see on küll mingi märk. See on ikka märk. Ikka otse taevast vä reaalselt. Noh,
Õpetaja: teevad tantsu, et kurat, tavaliselt on nad argiku teenus ja
Õpetaja: olge Ka nagu näha, siis Eesti majandus mõjub meile ka.
Õpetaja: Nad on ka ju toiduahelad. Ju majandus langeb ostukuid.
Õpetaja: Halvemaks välimus
Õpetaja: Mm.
Õpetaja: Tõmbame ka järele, Ee,
Õpetaja: ja tõmbagi.
Õpetaja: Kütame. Edasi
Õpetaja: tuttav. Huvitavaid loope
Õpetaja: ja muudega suuremad Jah,
Õpetaja: ai. Vabandust,
Õpetaja: siis, ei otsa aga. Kelle tahab siia ka
Õpetaja: aa Ei Läinud Stopi peale või ei pannud.
Õpetaja: Aga siis ma panen ainult päris Stop I.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleks. Ee, kaks.